welcome everybody to another episode of
a street podcast today's episode is
sponsored by Squarespace honey and quip
we have got an incredible flippin
episode to him back for you today okay
from first of all we have later coming
in the boys Jack and Eric
first of all already the best episode it
doesn't get better than that
until now we've got on the phone today
Kyle the Cougar champion you guys may
recall him from a recent video we did he
was featured in a TLC The Learning
Channel documentary about strange
addictions he's a 30 year old dude who
slam dunks on 90 year olds but he dates
exclusively older women and he basically
wrote to us after we made the video
talking about him saying like they they
miss portrayed him he wanted to clarify
a couple of things I have a couple of
things I want to clarify one thing Phil
but he's an interesting guy right I mean
who who of us have lived that life you
know what I mean
nobody to actually slay someone with
your penis is kind of like the ultimate
honor as a man it's like I [ __ ] I
killed her with my dick
I'll ask that's an accurate portrayal of
what he does in the bedroom so he's
lined up we're gonna get on the phone
with Kyle and then Jack and Eric are
gonna hop right in and it's the may the
force be with you memes a happy Star
Wars day in a way the new Star Wars are
fun but they've also kind of ruined the
specialness of Star Wars it used to be
may the may the fourth be with you in a
second this beautiful perfect franchise
everybody loves and now it's all like
that one was okay this one was mine it's
like there's nothing special there's han
solo origin movie coming out in like a
week it's like you know it'll probably
get a 70 and then all the sudden because
we all wrote off the prequels we're all
like well it's still perfect because
George came back and he's a little old I
don't know I see what you mean yeah
- I have fun watching it I'll leave it
you know just you know Ian the intern is
an adamant defender of the prequels he
loves them
whoa interesting yeah I'd like to be
arguing with him a few times in I'd like
to bring you on and possibly could you
prepare a dissertation and we can kind
of like challenge your thesis like a
doctorates degree he's out walking
shredder but when he gets back all I'll
see if he's something prepared he was
pretty passionate about he has
interesting theories in he's a free
thinker and under the Kanye and yeah all
right but enough of the [ __ ] by the
way next week we're taking a week off we
were trying to think I want to take a
vacation
yeah but then we're like oh let's go to
Hawaii did we talk about this hurry was
this somewhere else
I don't think you guys talked about not
okay I was like I want to go to Hawaii
oh I want to go to Europe I want to go
to Mexico and then I'm like hold on a
[ __ ] second these aren't vacations
these are always miserable works with so
much headache like you got to find a
flight and airport going to airports is
worse than any day at work you've ever
done unpacking right and then by the
time you get five days but yours worked
because like the last two days your
worrying was you're like oh I got a pack
of my [ __ ] up and go the airport yeah
every time we go to Israel we do that
every year it's not vacation let's be
frank it's pretty flippin far from
vacation so what I had this brilliant
idea no one's ever thought of it before
I was like you know what we're gonna do
I'm gonna turn off my phone I'm not
gonna look at social media I'm not gonna
do anything I'm just gonna chill in my
house
I'm gonna just relax that's a [ __ ]
vacation you remember when you were kids
summer vacation that was a vacation it
was such a vacation that you used to be
like I'm ready to go back to school
that's a vacation when you're like I'm
bored I got when we decided to do that I
all of a sudden got so excited I can't
wait like that sounds I mean yeah I'm
relieved I was like relieved I just like
the idea of not using my phone right
nothing no emails no anything I've been
feeling more and more
about how actually toxic all the social
media stuff going on and all the like I
mean how the frequent checking of the
phone and like either looking for like
news or read it post or Twitter or
Instagram something is satisfy you're
always searching for something like
interesting like where is it and you've
just you get less and less reward and
more and more time on and it really
feels like an addiction yeah it is
it's funny remember we used to make fun
of those videos but that guy makes it
more they that's the way that they do it
that I don't like like Prince ie where
he's like look up from your phone it's
more about he doesn't really approach it
from a way that that's like this is an
addiction and let's use this in
moderation it's like look up and don't
look down
look up I don't know the way they do
it's annoying yeah I'm just a guy
talking so the way I do it when I feel
it it's real you know I'm an [ __ ] he
was right yeah he was ahead of the game
but I feel like now more than ever
people are starting to realize like man
this [ __ ] is kind of like a no problem
yeah yeah our intern Ian he said he'd
erased all of his social media and he
has a lower brother who says he's
Instagram even more and it's like a real
problem
interesting the kids who are younger
than us have like new problems yeah cuz
I will grew up with the Internet but now
these kids who are coming up now were
born with social media right and that is
a whole new twisted mind [ __ ] to grow up
with I don't know it's really lately
it's just depressing me my god
Instagram used to be my favorite me too
and now I'm like every time I open it I
get depressed I don't know why
Facebook's paid then to me for a long
time but I still Facebook was my first
social media but I still after all this
time I don't use it I still reflexively
go type F in the browser go to Facebook
I don't look at it for very long maybe
like 30 seconds but I I hate being on
Facebook but I still after all this time
it's to go to the weird habit reddit
started to get really bad for me like
all all sit in bed and waste an hour
just scrolling reddit and and in my mind
I'm like I don't want to be doing this I
could be doing anything else but this
but like yo-yo is a friend of an hour so
so it used to be like the joy I enjoyed
it and I was in the moment but now I'm
wanting to be doing something else but
so yeah through it yeah it's weird
so bad it's a weird thing it sounds like
everyone is feeling it too like
especially lately yeah what are they
doing cuz you know they're doing [ __ ] to
like manipulate you for sure you know
since Facebook bought Instagram I've
been reading stuff about how they'll
specifically underreport likes on your
posts so that you will think that it's
underperforming and you'll keep checking
it my god out of insecurity like how
twisted how sick and you be when did
they buy Instagram they did it secretly
happen like I don't know a year ago but
I was longer than that how was it yeah
it was but that was that was so smart of
them thing one day that's why I hate cuz
it used to be my favorite one they're
getting more manipulative with the
stories the stories keep you on yeah duh
I don't know and now they started like
the like thing them and they started
switching the order it's no longer
chronological yeah I hate that and so
it's really all about manipulating you
at any cost
no ethical to be a consideration exactly
just to spend as much time on it as
possible well anyway let's talk good to
Kyle the grandma [ __ ] I wonder what's
his social media like well I'm really
looking forward to that vacation I'm
gonna really just try to unplug and what
I'm gonna try I'm looking in the chat
right now and a lot of people are saying
they feel exactly the same yeah I don't
know there's something in the air work
just suddenly we should gotten really it
should be like a national thing where
everyone takes a week off of everything
damn that'd be that'd be killer next
week urge that'd be really cool next
week guys do it let's all do it together
seriously
like leave the calls on if there's an
emergency people can call you sure but
no text no anything yeah I'm really
looking forward to it and and one thing
I want to focus on is like just doing
things that are I know are good for me
during that time like I'm not gonna work
I'm gonna enjoy myself I'm gonna play
video games and stuff but I'm not gonna
like drink not gonna order pizza nook
and what what I want to do is focus on
like exercising every morning because
usually I make excuses like oh I don't
have time I have too much [ __ ] yeah
right gotta work I'm busy browsing
reddit for an hour every morning so what
I want to try to do is like take care of
stuff around the house mm-hmm get in the
habit of exercise every morning eating
healthy and just having like a holistic
experience of like wellness I love that
idea
so we'll see where we're at so yeah
looking forward to that
so no podcast next week um but hey you
know what okay let's get back on track
so Kyle the cougar champ a lot of you
probably know who he is a lot of you
probably don't so I'm gonna play a
little clip here to bring you guys all
up to speed whoo-hoo those who are and
not familiar with your boy the great
Blenheim's column I'm 31 I live in
Pittsburgh and older women
where's the [ __ ] mouse button much
older women right I can find it like 60
70 80 year old older women all the smell
you have something to say no I just I
love that says I love this man yeah I
love this smell it's like I want to
actually ask him what did they smell
like what is what is how how do they
smell like what is the smell cuz when I
think of older women I think like like
musky closet like positive oh yeah
stinky how is that I guess he likes that
maybe like he smell old socks I don't
know
I loved interest seriously like ladies I
promise you telling your man the
interest will not turn them off it'll
put a smile on his face they'll put a
smile on his pants
okay I want to know who wrote that line
for her about the dentures vendors will
put a smile in your pants so anyway this
guy he's really enthusiastic and
actually what we found out after we made
this video is that
well he's dating a 91 year old currently
or I don't know if she's in one of the
videos that way but he we later discover
he makes porn he's a pornographer mm-hm
and he he [ __ ] old ladies on camera I
don't know if that's his primary
business but I have so many questions
for him
so with that being said let's let's
bring him out man Kyle uh let's grab him
Kyle the cougar champion are you there
hey it's good to be here man under the
weather I have a cold
yeah good to be here you sound great man
don't worry about it but first of all
let me just say what a honor and thrill
it is to be in the presence of the one
and only cougar champion is that
something is that a title you've given
yourself or was that anointed by others
that was something on what I decided I
was going to do porn I had to pick a
name and that's just the name I came up
with and there's a hell of that guy
won't talk to oh oh oh yeah let me fix
that Dan Heath these got feedback can
you hear me Dan yeah you know what here
let me uh it's kind of loud in there
yeah yeah let me alone all right Kyle's
ahead try that now okay is that better I
can hear you okay okay great so um you
had this grit well first of all what is
it actually
you're dated a 91 year old right okay at
the time that video was shooting they
they portrayed it they wrote it as a
heart and I would never do monogamy
anyone that's so I guess well did you
were you having sex with the 91 year old
Oh
[ __ ] for a while and you know stalls
me on my shampoo the point of all of it
Oh was that with her eye on astad I
couldn't hang for that long good I'm
sorry
there was a video she had some tats
around her nipples I was like damn this
lady's [ __ ] really seen some [ __ ]
talking about Shirley the one that
wasn't the that was the addiction that
was but let me ask you this when you're
when you're slamming on a on a 91 year
old are you more do you have to be more
gentle because I know you you have quite
a bit of rain she'll go anywhere from
like seventy to a hundred I don't know
where you draw the line but like are you
more gentle when you when you slam dunk
on older ladies yeah okay what are you
ever concerned about damaging the goods
I mean what wrong thrust to be it could
be a it could be the last one no you
broke [ __ ] dude tell me about that
situation words make it what not what a
tear in the back of my [ __ ] what the
smiley face I'm glad to stitch her up we
couldn't do anything for like six weeks
how did that make you feel
did you feel bad or accomplished a
little bit of both actually has anyone
ever died well while you've been in a
relationship with them yeah
Marge died at 94 Connie get on the
website she passed away last year when
does passed away and Linda passed away
passed away like all right what does
that are you like in touch with their
family when someone passes away like I
do you go to the funeral does it how do
you feel like when they pass away and is
that like a like what's the what's the
emotion that you experience because you
you got to know when you get when you
get with these ladies that that's a
strong possibility right that they
they're their own expiry date
sorry
Connie's the one from the video right
the one that was too young for you damn
well damn Doug tell me about so when you
mention that dentures put a smile in
your pants like was that something that
that you offered to the camera or was
that something that the producers helped
you dream up as much as I hate doing
minute that was just total Emma
and it's I love how you say that line of
like I guarantee you all men love your
dentures do you think that all
non-refundable ladies or my gum job is
that what it's all about your expenses
yeah that's a new standard so describe
what gum job to me I mean it's getting a
[ __ ] but like there's no there's no
chance of teeth scraping your [ __ ] off
right and you asked for a gum job or a
[ __ ] when you when you present the
opportunity to them well there's a lot
of times I can look at the woman I can
tell she answers I won't bring it up at
first well she'll say she's going down
on me but somehow a secretary thought
well usually it first would be nervous
about all that babe it's cool trust me
it feels way better in the mouth damn
and then they pop out the dentures and
it's all about the gum at that point
it's a GJ so when you notice that girl
has dentures does that excite you now
you had mentioned that when you slam on
these old ladies you'll even put their
legs up behind their heads that is a bit
of a shock to me I was gonna ask what
position you engage them because there's
some what seem to be somewhat fragile
but in it it seems like are you trying
to break them is that part of the thrill
[Laughter]
and the Pretender Paul I want to hold
our head underwater while I [ __ ] her
in her ass
that is crazy wait how do you get to
that point that is sex get to that point
different position however obviously
can't get away car composition so on the
camera I mean I think you'd be really
surprised as to how but on the other
hand you did break two [ __ ] recently
over honey I was going oh well um damn
by the way the audio is a little [ __ ]
is there anything to do about that I'm
working on I tried to adjust the EQ a
little bit but honestly it just sounds
like his reception is getting a little
okay yeah how many how many ladies old
ladies would you say you've slammed by
now do you have the exact number you
keep you know you keep behind Wyatt why
do you I'm curious why do you keep that
guard at that exact number Oh care about
a lot right no well you already said
over a hundred like I mean what's the
big what can be really be that big of a
[Music]
star trekkin sister EVER fold homeland
has pictures and [ __ ] like nudes yeah
together yeah yeah Wow is that [ __ ] like
wow that's pretty nice he did do you
keep like hair or anything like that
what about ash
that's anyone been cremated and have you
collected their ash alright let me ask
you this have you ever been put in
someone's will because it wouldn't haha
because it would make sense that these
cuz these old ladies they really I mean
you guys have like emotional bonds like
they really it's a beautiful thing when
you come into their lives they seem very
happy to have that companionship so what
didn't surprise me at all if they're
like you know what I want to leave this
guy a little bit of something just know
you're actually working out very well
but I mean a lot of times people look at
me a stereotype me so you're just
[ __ ] full of money when you're
talking because I give you this and that
um he actually gave me way too much
pleasure smiles almost love them it's
actually rare that becomes like an
emotional thing
most of the time it most of the time
lost at home just alcohol in sex most of
the time I would actually like I would I
would assume the difference is because
they're kind of lonely on ladies and now
someone all the sons interest in them
it's like spree sparking older flames
you know it makes sense to me that
they're like it's a more of an emotional
thing for them than than a sexual one I
mean these women have all been through
man no come on usually the majority of
the time it's alcohol
staying up [ __ ] all night that's the
majority of the time but then
occasionally they're all ones here and
they're like um listening right now it's
a courtesy nonpoint last weekend you
know the rock being on point I know I
don't
okay well I'll take her see it's a lot
that sort of sees them on last week when
we had drink the ball ball was fine by
me here and there we have to call a
dressing on a Chanel way to see Mel in
there for Chili's in Mexico um there are
ones that are but yeah you do have balls
relationships but the majority in the
time I suspect that's interesting cuz if
you hook up with an old lady is she
always coming at you with like the text
and [ __ ] like what's it like to be text
that by an old lady who doesn't even
really know how to use a phone or maybe
that's a plus for you loose ends no lose
a huge house a huge misconception I used
to work for a major self over hot rod
now and I was in the stores
these old people know how to use cell
phones that's why I'm kind of pictures
of like [ __ ] and cuts and video to
them going on yes that we're being
texted to pay for them in their 60 to 70
have you what someone might be context
will go what's the richest old lady been
with do you have you ever landed like a
real rich sugar mama you like took you
to nice dinners and stuff I never asked
for a nice chef on in I would say the
one I also - I never googled her net
worth I never look how much they're
worth but there was warm if I had to
guess probably the most well off I was
dating a lady in Pittsburgh who was like
a head nurse of somewhere and at one
point she says to me she goes you know
I'm basically rich I'm gonna move to
Florida once you come with me
you know what's her I said no no she
goes why not I was like oh I wanna hate
you in a week I'll become a [ __ ]
apply it you don't mean oh so they're
far off in the military like it for
after I lost military I'm sitting there
in Iraq I'm telling the story to my
friends with my friends like man you're
an [ __ ] what why well you can't be a
form of smoking so grandma take care of
you but no you're [ __ ] Iraq you're a
dumbass
again well I never I never I never
researched or network I don't know [ __ ]
yeah I see a shot I will definitely say
into your credit that you don't [ __ ] 130
old women if it's about money
that's love for some old grandma [ __ ]
right there let me ask you you said in
the in the video that when you were in
high school you realize you were
attracted to older ladies because you
had this hot older
teacher and that's when you realize you
were tracked with old ladies I feel like
there's more to that story I feel like a
dis lifelong fetish has got to be born
from something a little bit more than
that what do you have a relationship
with her oh yeah I didn't seing the and
the TLC you just made a brief anecdote
about it started when or maybe yeah I
don't I don't know about any
funny why that the teachers I was
referencing honestly I never touched
their you know my a these doors Menino
town but he just [ __ ] their students
like wherever they were I was a kid I
can say the first older woman I ever had
I mean I was 17 she was 34 but that
doesn't count these not not to meet them
um
she um a high schooler she was an art
teacher from college and she was there
just to me by a friend especially to her
mom that was that big diva calamy
because now I will look at you and
respect you're just you were just born
being into older ladies I feel like that
kind of stuff like like nothing ever
happened we're with the older lady like
she you know no question by saying
that's you know what do you like grow up
that's why I got Wireless guys I mean
you know your people are wired how
they're wired what your inter
interesting
do you uh go out for God the the oldest
lady you've dated is 91 right or was
there anyone older than that oh let's
say we were dating but the last time
thank you Father
whatever yeah [ __ ] the last time of
her life section when he walked on 93
you know you're talking about I can't
imagine that's like 93 year old I've
never met a 93 year old that wasn't just
like on the verge of death you know
what's funny about that um but last time
her and I had sex she was 93 that videos
on my website right now right now guys
is this your full-time job that you're a
pornographer oh no not even close I
don't make I don't think nearly as much
as me on what they committed that's
basically [ __ ] money I mean I don't
make that's not my job my even close I'm
close
what is your full-time job okay
oh I mean we'll say a couple years ago I
had a great job and I really liked
that's if it was just amazing and then I
got found out at work yeah every fire of
you because of the porn so far yeah you
feel discriminated here until
ladies not really funny jokes over the
years my name by the way like the pcj on
your on the YouTube video or [ __ ]
hilarious I mean you know grape I've
heard some really effort to really funny
jokes or personally shitty jokes over
the years I really I like it depending
on the contact so well was all in the
Marines years ago there are some
serious-ass holy towards what I was
doing I'm very [ __ ] right
all right Kyle thanks for calling in man
I don't know how I feel about what
you're doing but I do feel like in a
weird way
why don't I don't like to hear the [ __ ]
breaking that much I know that's
probably you know it's a hazard of the
job but you are bringing love and warmth
into the lives of these old ladies right
you bring in tenderness and and you just
keep smashing those [ __ ] ugh just do
your thing all right keep going ups
I really appreciate hey god bless you do
you keep slamming literally right here
dude
well that was a thrill well the boys are
here yeah the boys are here boys are
here I need to unpack that experience
boy need to decompress a little bit so
hope you guys enjoyed that I was a
[ __ ] wild ride we're gonna take a
commercial break we will be back by the
way it's may the 4th be with you but
it's also Cinco de Mayo and we've got
what is it called margaritas on thick I
got my brain fried well think of all
these gum jobs and stuff
the GJ a GJ a Jeep yeah anyway guys um
we'll be right back with the boys it's
gonna be right stay tuned
do not go anywhere
this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
that's a command I'm pissed
why am I so angry all the time when I do
these carpentry or not you decide I'll
give you some passionate I'm Pat it's
passion and it sounds like you're angry
yeah it's not anger I'm gonna give you
information you decide if this is a good
choice for you okay here's here's the
information you decide Squarespace
templates make creating a powerful
online identity even easier and you can
create a beautiful website with
Squarespace to turn key solution it's
all in one you sign up everything you
need is there you don't need to be a
programmer you don't need to be a NASA
scientist to create a beautiful website
that lets you express who you really are
see I didn't I didn't go up I stayed
down I'm giving you information
Squarespace allows you to manage your
products orders an inventory easily
that's an interest that's a good selling
point they also track sales gain
customer insight and grow your customer
base all within Squarespace using their
customer management and commerce
analytics Wow not at all dude
all-in-one baby turnkey Squarespace
makes it easy to learn by providing
webinars workshops in 24/7 customer
support they want you to succeed because
when you succeed they succeed that was
great that felt good swear Suisse makes
it simple to set up or transfer your
domains so if you're ever interested in
building a site for your own shop your
own e-commerce but karma ecommerce
business or maybe you just have a atomic
Gucci collection that you really want to
share with the world doesn't have to be
commerce right I want to see that
website too so you have no excuse now
destiny is calling cuz once you put
those tamo Gucci's online your loan will
never be the same
it says unique destiny says you need a
new website now go make that website
with Squarespace head to squarespace.com
/ht to start your free 14-day trial and
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain again that's
Squarespace
calm /h 3 go feel it out see what's
there you got 14 days for free see if
you like it alright I'm not gonna get
angry about it but I I'm a big fan of
Squarespace thank you for sponsoring us
next up what can you say about honey the
greatest browsing app of all time okay
first of all we've talked about honey
previously and and I've installed this
browser and I'm not I'm not blowing
smoke up your ass just in between the
last time we talked about it we bought
we were we bought Jack he had a registry
for wedding gifts and we we bought a
gift late so it wasn't that much left
but there was one item at the top that
was like 600 and we're like all right
let's pony up for this guy he's a good
friend let's get him these $600 sheets
by the way who's that was a bird schwa
play of them to put a $600 sheets on the
registry but you know I was up for the
challenge so we go or some normal ones
to not to make them yeah yeah it was
more like a challenge like who the who
wants who is gonna pay for this one who
wants to be a real friend today anyway I
did so we go over to Macy's and and
we're checking out we're ready to drop
600 bones and honey's like uh-uh
I don't think so it saved us 360 mocks
and so from 600 we only spent 240 don't
tell Jack because he thinks we got the
most expensive gift but now if you
compare it to everything else it was
like kind of middle of the road so don't
tell jack whatever you do because he
thinks for like top dogging it but it
turns out no just a nice gift when you
shop online do you suddenly turn into a
tab hoarder loading dozens and dozens of
new tabs on your browser in search of a
promo code just one that works afraid to
close any of them and fear of missing
out of a deal that's pretty neurotic
it's not that serious but you know I
guess our seriuos it's like yeah sounds
like they're freaking out Sarah was like
yeah that's me I was like sorry I don't
think you're neurotic but me and Sarah
we both have a lot of a lot of tabs open
what are you coupon searching because
like yeah
before but anyway that's a problem of
the past before you crash your browser
yet again try honey honey is the free
browser add-on that over nine million
people are using every single flippin
day to save money while they shop online
and to clicks add honey to any browser
for free then shop like you normally do
and he scans and tests millions of
coupons in the background I check out
honey automatically applies the best
coupon Time magazine calls honey
basically free money
forget about what Time magazine says and
I call it basically free money you
should call it literally literally yeah
I need that I was saying I need an
upgrade what they said can you honey I'm
talking to you got can you remove this
and say ethan klein calls it literally
free money you can get like sued it's
not literally free money you can buy
something it's it's literally honey
sending you money in the mail and if you
can expect to check every month no I'm
kidding over nine million people are
using honey every day and together they
saved millions of dollars I cannot
endorse this product enough it's so easy
to install and I guarantee you before
too long you're gonna be saving money
from with this thing it's gonna blow you
away there's no reason not to add honey
to your browser today it's free takes
just two clicks to install will save you
tons of cash get honey for free at join
honey calm /h Street that's two words
join honey calm /h three to start with
honey today that's join honey calm /h
three thank you so much to honey for
sponsoring us and finally everybody's
favorite electric toothbrush quip which
has changed my life for the better I
can't get enough of this little
vibrating tube and it's so slick the
design is so slick you put it on your
mirror like whatever surface you've got
and then you you put your quip in there
you holster it you'd holster your damn
vibrating toes glue here it's freakin
unbelievable here oh I think I already
took it off yeah we already let me tell
you about quit
I use this every morning it's uh it's
changed my life in terms of brushing
first of all the bristles are soft it's
rubber which is unusual or that has some
oh come on you know that's not a good
demonstration [ __ ] obviously don't put
it on your laptop
no well we've we've used this yeah it
works for a while so
but the toothbrush okay the toothbrush
it's got soft bristles you turn it on it
vibrates dentists have said for a long
time the vibrating tooth brush cleaner
mouth better but that's not even the
best part about it it tells you how long
you need to brush because a lot of you
slobs out there I mean ah let's be
honest don't brush your teeth for long
enough you live for example she says she
brushed her teeth she got the buzz and
she's like oh man I was already done but
she knows that she has to keep going
mm-hmm I personally I'm I'm extremely
bizarre I brushed for like 30 minutes
it's probably not healthy sometimes I
feel like I burned my tongue because of
the two places in my mouth so long ago
regardless regardless it tells you how
long to brush for it tells you when to
switch from top to bottom you are gonna
have a beautiful clean satisfying brush
and here's the best part
it starts at just 25 bucks big
name-brand toothbrushes you got to get a
mortgage out on your house to buy that
[ __ ] it's like $200 who's got time for
that garbage and it's delivered right to
your flippin door okay Oprah even likes
it they make me say that here
Oprah likes it who cares about Oprah I'm
endorsing it why do I need to say that
Oprah
forget about Oprah I can guarantee you
she doesn't use the toothbrush she has
some she has some toothbrush that's made
of like Egyptian silk like a goddamn
handle you think Oprah uses this come on
she has a leaves that brush her teeth
Oprah's a billionaire I'm a normal guy I
love this all right change this but I
put it on my oh wow list plus they're
backed by 20,000 dentists and hygienists
and hundreds of thousands of happy
brushes I love this toothbrush give it a
shot you will not regret it
clip starts at 25 bucks go to get clip
dot-com I mean 25 I don't know what I
said get clipped calm /ht right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush you pop
off the top you pop on a noop top every
three months they send it to you in the
mail and you never have to worry about
buying toothbrushes and shopping for
crap you know it sucks when you buy
toothbrush because you can't really try
it and then you don't like it you throw
it out like oh well yeah maybe that's me
I don't know people are that neurotic
but like if you get one that's too stiff
they'll [ __ ] your gums up it literally
hurts my mouth get your first refill
pack free at get quit calm / 3 /h 3
that's GE TQ u IP comm /h 3 give them a
shot and thank you to all of our
sponsors you guys they make the show
possible so if you're in the market
please support them with that being said
let's get right back in with Jack and
Eric the boys the boys calm down this is
the part where you cut me off welcome
back everybody the h3 podcast here with
the boys from common etiquette and
jacksFilms I love you guys these my
favorite episodes we come we drink we
laughed we smile we CAD we cry sometimes
sometimes sometimes we [ __ ] grandmas
compress compress I just had an intense
moment I wanted to first talk about well
first of all Jack you were just recently
married so congratulations thank you
very much I'll drink to that and you all
were at the beautiful wedding dude that
was one of the worst moments of my life
yeah why just because I believe no
longer tango man no I don't know I and
the fact that you don't know why is good
yeah yeah tell you you didn't I didn't I
didn't what I feel like that would have
been better so the image I don't know
we've lived in Israel for so long I
don't know how invitations to weddings
work apparently it's like it says 4
o'clock it says and we're like ok
because in Israel it's like weddings at
4:00 show up at 6:00 okay
I see the answer it's work I think I
know that's how a lot of things work I
started about four that's how part is
that we started about four I guess in
America when you write weddings at four
that means your ass is up there saying
vows at 4:10 right so when did you
someone is you guys show up so we roll
up around like 4:11 we roll up and I'm
taking my it's not terrible but we rest
oh I see okay and I roll up in the
valets like I'm like I'm here for the
wedding and he's like the one at four
and I was like yeah we've done this good
attitude good nothing for you so we're
going in the bathroom we're taking her
time we're getting dressed yeah and then
we're walking towards the where the
wedding's happening and they go you know
follow the path whatever so we're
falling right path and then we end up
walking through this restaurant we're
like hey where's the wedding I figured
the restaurant was somehow associated
and we walk through there like oh no
it's that way so I walk through a double
doors and right in you're you're getting
married right there and right right here
field of vision yeah literally jack is
facing here and I'm walking through a
door during this ceremony did you see me
no not at all I did not I mean I know
like so stressed at that moment I was it
was it was just like the the it was a
lot of things like like I was I don't
want to say nervous but like you know
it's just the ceremonies happening
I was so oblivious to everything that
was happening outside no I know exactly
where you're referencing I know exactly
where that is
right closer right in front oh it
couldn't be closer to where we were
literally getting with nobody else there
it was in so I was like oh my god he
definitely I was like oh my god why did
they tell me to come through here first
of all so then we go around and
everybody's sitting there's pretty much
no spare seats and I'm like I'm so
[ __ ] embarrassed can't believe I
didn't see this did you see this so I'm
and of course a part of me in my mind is
like of course my own embarrassment is
somehow paramount in my mind to your
beautiful special moment I'm like this
is so embarrassing and not being like
this is such a magical beautiful thing
no I get it I get it like that's yeah
that's better so I walk up around and
it's actually more of an intimate
wedding than I expected it how many
people were there
121 wow they really squeezed them you
know squeezed a minute they did that's
I look like 50 yeah oh wow well at any
rate so we walk up and the ushers like
I'm like there's no way I'm gonna go sit
down and interrupt the ceremony I'm so
[ __ ] embarrassed I'm just gonna stand
back here and the ushers like no it's
fine it's fine go ahead it's fine
there's seats in the front row oh no and
I'm like I'm not gonna sit in the front
row you're insane I'm just gonna stand
back here and and then there was this
whole thing of like it's more
embarrassing that you're standing back
there Oh sitting I I swear man we would
not have noticed we really liked if you
were wearing all pink I with polka-dots
we would have you know because we're
just like this the whole time you know
yeah like you never would have noticed
you weren't wearing a tux either or
anything well they're really there
really isn't there wasn't a dress code
specified it was just you know it was I
mean it wasn't it wasn't black-tie like
it wasn't anything like that yeah it's
just look look nice and I'm sure you and
you did we were freaking out that maybe
there was also like a dress code anyone
following that was wearing like a bomber
it was I was fully we're just in panic
the whole time basically then this is
when I get really good the usher and Eli
are like arguing and I'm just in the
corner embarrassed there's fighting yeah
yeah but she's like just go sit in the
front right nobody won't will notice I'm
like all right let's just [ __ ] go so
we go up first of all who's on the right
side whose parents were on the right
side on facing us yeah
from my audience that would be my be my
parents yeah yeah yeah so they walk us
up to the front [ __ ] row and then
there's like four maybe six feet seats
available but people put their stuff on
it and the only two seats available were
right next to your parents so they bring
us up to the front row and sit us next
to your parents and your parents turn to
us like who the [ __ ] are these
and I was just bro I could I was dying I
was dying I I wanted fire in your shoes
I'd be dying too but I had already you
should have turned to Jack's mom had
been like [ __ ] guys okay
pure wonderful moment yeah yeah well
thank you very much you guys right it
was just so funny to hear because we
hadn't no clue at all I'm really happy
to hear that because I figured you had
seen us coming through there and been
like those [ __ ] are not only late
they're not dressed right they're
interrupting our ceremony you know if
they're much you could have done in that
situation other than like hide behind a
bush that's what I was doing Oh off to
the side like I yeah was there like
watching through a bush and like I sure
you don't want to sit right with the
string quartet kind of nudged in that a
little alcove that's what it was you
knock out the band and then you'll occur
not smart I wouldn't really smart it
man-style see I'm hoping the
videographer got some of this so that I
can I can relive it yeah there was one
in particular that we kind of had to
even like crawl under I'm sure it's
there oh my god that's well oh yeah it
was an absolute blur the entire day like
the ceremony was super short cocktail
hour we were there for about five
minutes and then the band was there for
four hours but if really felt like I
heard about thirty minutes of music that
because I was just such the day was over
so quickly and because a lot of it is
that the photographers keep pulling us
they kept pulling us aside more pictures
by the beach pictures about the sunset
you know let's get the the groom's you
know we'd really have groomsmen but
let's get the groomsmen for this and bah
blah blah and so that it's allows a big
part of it like you know in dinner we
sit down to dinner
okay can you get up gotta go the Sun
setting so we got to get that golden
that magic our shot of the two of you
guys and I'm glad they didn't like when
we get the photographs I'll be very
happy they did all that but like the it
was I think it was a perfect I say I
think because like I think it was it was
just so overwhelming in the best way
possible but for us the experience was
just so fast especially the actual
reception the the reception part of
dinner and the band and everything was
over so quickly and then all of a sudden
boom it's the after-party interest and
it's in the wee hours in the morning
we're in the after-party segment already
and that's what cats that's what kept
scrolling through my head like so it's
already and Erin throughout the day Erin
kept saying to me like I can't believe
it's already over
not that it's here it's already over
yeah so that's kind of sad but like
because you plan your base like a
wedding as you guys know is your
planning just the biggest worry yeah for
a year you're planning the biggest party
of your lives that's all the wedding is
it's just and there goes a month and a
half of planning I I believe it's just
that that's what they don't tell you
that's what they don't tell you about
weddings that is just it's over so
quickly so I'm dying to get all the
we're both we just want to relive
through photographs in through videos
yeah like God we for the next week all
we did was just sit in bed looking at
other people's Instagram stories uh-huh
and you know just because we just we
were like oh that happened apparently
someone was juggling candles and we
didn't know that we didn't see because
they kept pulling us or like it was just
it was so much of that damn
but were you ever like dude just leave
me alone just know because I it I never
I can't say I was ever annoyed because
for me it was just kind of like alright
here we go
because I knew it would be worth it in
the end like I want these these these
memories captured on some kind of yeah
definitely format because I'm not
clearly I don't remember half of what
happened I remember quarter of what
happened
yeah and I need like evidence I need
hard physical evidence right you haven't
said all that stuff up yourself anyway
so like if you were to say no you would
have just been saying - no right right -
my hate for like to do this right sir i
obligated contractually to be here [ __ ]
off you wrote me a note that said if you
tell me to [ __ ] off that I insist I wish
I were that smart to plan an extra
charge right right well it was great
there was such an alike eclectic group
of people like I was hanging out with
idubbbz and the fine brothers in New
York one but yeah there's a whole
youtube table with nine brothers were
just and you know what I probably
shouldn't say this but which was the guy
we're hanging out with always getting
mixed up was robbing Iran okay but
people need to know this about him he
had a cigarette with us yeah you didn't
you didn't think you and I is a similar
but we have peer pressured him I was
like pretty heavily Ian made the
cigarette right yeah it was crazy what I
did actually he first of all that's not
he I was shocked by how no fight I was
like yo do you want a cigarette almost
like as a joke like smoke the cigarette
and he was like like by the time I
finished was like Barbara oh man well I
mean like you're not a smoker but every
time I'm around you're like you're
speaking with all right yeah now you got
a dog in here and I'm trying to make a
dog I'm sorry I mean I've been making
you smell cigarette you don't want to
get can dogs get second conducts get a
coffee you want to find out I was just
gonna say yeah hard science yeah I'll be
right back okay a quick errand um well
yeah it was great fun yeah time just
talking with everyone I mean it's it's
the one time besides a funeral that
you'll have everyone that you love in
your life in one room together and so it
was just I spoke to just about everyone
I wanted to just about
the funeral funeral is any day now I
keep drinking like this anything gonna
be a band by the way the day was
incredible - it was like perfect Santa
Barbara yeah like ooh we got so lucky
two days later when we were like walking
out or checking out it was crazy cloudy
and like if we like any later we
scheduled that wedding it would have
gone to [ __ ] we got so it was it was
just the perfect day yeah like months
ago I months ago Aaron was checking the
weather and you can't predict the
weather in a month in advance but it was
saying stuff like you know possibility
of rain possibility of rain and she was
like it better not I cannot ya cannot
and it didn't of course of course it did
not even a cloud really no not at all
not at all it's just it was really
blessed I it was it was idyllic you paid
the shadow masters to see the sky with a
cloud clearing well that wasn't me that
was a wedding coordinator yeah well okay
let's get some let's get some margaritas
in here yeah are we turning up here
today sure I've got a ton of [ __ ] to get
to first on my list
is Kanye Twitter there's a lot to sift
Guerra following a little bit hello I
mean like I don't follow him on Twitter
but I followed the conversing one of the
great questions before we get into this
is is this a performance piece is he
just stirring controversy to promote his
new album or not even that but just to
stir controversy in a way one of his
most controversial things among his
peers was that he's endorsing Trump
right even further he's shit-talking
Obama he said Obama was prison for eight
years and things didn't get better in
Chicago for example he said that so one
thing that I've wondered and I've seen a
lot of people speculating is like is
this you know does he really believe
this right we do not I don't I don't
want to speak for the group by okay we
don't I don't take salt on my room can
you lick it off
thank you guys Wow really Cheers
let's continue this wedding so Kanye's
new album
I'm just saying Chicago hasn't gotten
better so hey have you been following it
Eric um yeah I mean like I feel like
it's like clockwork the guys got an
album coming out so Ryan he's gonna get
his name out there but is it genuine
though I mean it's not say it's not
genuine maybe it's something he's been
like hmm thinking and being like oh this
be a good way to like he's being genuine
about it but he knows the effect it'll
have on giving him sure he's aware of
Lily yeah I don't I mean I don't know I
don't know if this if it's because of
the upcoming album because I think I do
think he believes these things I really
do I don't think it's to sensationalize
his upcoming album I think it's just
he's he's known for saying brash things
he's been doing it for the better part
of a decade now I don't I don't think
it's I may be a little bit of it is
related but he doesn't have to heat like
his album will sell whether or not he
says crazy dumb things although he's
kind of been under the radar now he's
like in the cultural mind like
everywhere but it could also be a result
of him creatively getting out there
again like the act of making music and
getting out there are this kind of new
thoughts and stuff I don't know and he
feels more encouraged to just share say
his thoughts now there he has an album
that's an interesting perspective yeah
well regardless whatever he's done he's
never been like almost I don't want to
say alienated but he's never been
ostracized by his own community before
yes this is it's like kind of a first
yeah cuz so anyway a lot of people may
not let's let's go through the history
of the Kanye tweets he actually had had
his Twitter deactivated until April 13th
over a year of blackout Twitter but so
all of a sudden he just woke up one day
it was like let's [ __ ] go oh well
that might be part of it then yeah I
mean that has to be part of it yeah like
I didn't realize for a whole year
nothing deactivated not only not only
nothing but deactivated I
I didn't know they could do that to a
figure such as Kanye and then he well he
did it they didn't oh the way you the
way you said it made it sound like heat
like he was [ __ ] this guy right okay
like like Jack himself or whatever a
Twitter not a fan of Jack of easy jack
Jack hates him yeah like shot him dead
right yeah not cause of anything he's
dead he's just my graduation was his
best you guys feel like Twitter does
things where they like censor like
people of political persuasions and
people there's a spirit a lot of
conspiracy theories about yeah Twitter
shutting down people I would love to see
that meeting of the minds at Twitter
headquarters were like it's very
sinister there in like a dimly lit room
they're like alright who do we press
yeah cuz I shut down uh Joss Whedon for
a bit right like oh he said some
interesting well I do well he's on the
left side right cuz I always hear from
conservatives so that kind of counters
there right Syria it does it does so I'm
not sure how they maybe there are some
key words like like kill or like I don't
know there have there has to be some
algorithmic things going on there behind
the scenes but I don't know how they
really choose cuz it is it is kind of
right but it happens on both sides they
really didn't yeah that that kind of
nullifies that argument but I've seen a
lot of like no no what you're talking
about yeah it's almost always based on
like harassment and [ __ ] like most
definitely um like somebody getting
their things shut down it's usually
because they were just they say in a day
[ __ ] how do I still have a Twitter no
but you're playful and fun my tweets the
Ted Cruz are like a paper bag full of
jizz and like nothing you gotta step up
to death threats that's how you get bad
you should make a video walking died in
our intro that would be such a good
video if you're challenging yourself to
get back yeah Twitter like me getting
banned from all kinds of things
right um like there's something awful
for
which call box getting banned from there
right you just reply to anything
low-tech says if you alright yeah
something Awful's Jesus yeah we love a
pop would love to see you making some
death threats to take those right let's
let's kick it up a notch by anyway Kanye
so he comes out are you comes out April
18th he says can I move this over and
like is this helpful to me no I just
kind of want to keep looking at that
logo it's just it's not there click the
wink damn booth is my goal controversy
is my Jim is that almost contradictory
in a way okay hold on let me analyze
this alright I rather digest truth is my
goal controversy is my Jim and songs
that if truth is our goal why would you
need well that's really dumb yeah if
controversy is what's makes you strong
yeah I mean controversy is almost at
odds with truth in a way you shouldn't
be controversial true you should be
controversial for controversy yeah fake
like that stuff being caught like that's
like being edgy for edgy sake that's
dumb don't do that like what he's trying
to imply that the truth is always
controversial and I mean that it's not
though yeah it's not sometimes the truth
is just boring next time my girlfriend
tells me I need to go to the gym I'm
gonna do a couple reps of controversy
also your girlfriend tells you to go to
the gym that's my everyday yeah she
doesn't like my blood pressure that's
Erin currently has a girlfriend although
every time completely shows up somewhere
he's like oh she's busy he broke her leg
she's a job in Canada yeah nice yeah
it's fine I'll do a hundred reps to kind
of about anime body pillow you [ __ ] just
it's cool to be honest yeah well I have
that too
they're called waifu's thank you what I
knew I was like is that how you
pronounce that I've always gone way Fuu
oh maybe it is no we need to fine you
make it serious I thought it was white
oh that's when you step it up you know
the way Phil I'm Way out of my element
here let us know in the comments what
you call your anime body
rips so anyway this was his first tweet
I think that kind of set you up with the
expertise you know that's the tone by
the way god help us he's planning on
running for president in 2024 hold on
easy though I feel like that's part of
what he loves about Trump oh ok mind
whatever mind you did what he loves
about Trump is that he's like just a guy
no different or better than me maybe
even worse than me I'm more famous I'm
more controversial if he can be
President so can i they're both
incredibly narcissistic rise the the
common thread I see you think yeah I
mean it's not like I think I could [ __ ]
on both of those guys just by how I feel
about them but it's pretty tough to
argue that they're not narcissists yeah
I agree
yeah yeah yeah yeah they thrive on it
but I mean [ __ ] the thing is so maybe
that's what the dragon energy is talking
dragons just [ __ ] love themselves his
presidential strategy is kind of
interesting because he's courting
conservatives with his Trump love in a
big way I've seen like responses of like
you see black people do get it some
black people do get it and like he it's
gonna be a crazy one dude let's run
Kayne I want to see that let's just
embrace the circus that's careful what
you wish for
I wanted Trump to win for that reason
and now look what this is even more
insane this is even more of a circus I
can yeah but in this in this post Trump
world we live in I can see it happening
if it gets at the point really we get
like all out like boxing matches instead
of [ __ ] debates right so it's just
idiocracy yeah
it's just a live-action idiocracy I mean
it pretty much is as much of an equal
amount of information that you'll get
from a boxing boxing match as a
modern-day presidential election like
yeah he looks good yeah although for him
I like the way he there you know
dachshund right yeah I kind of wish he
would run against Trump though I don't
know why he's got to wait for 24 can you
imagine though I mean he just might
let's just keep encouraging him yeah
let's make it happen let's make it
happen why wait for 24 yeah
man up dude maybe's got a shot at the
midterms
it comes just the Senate you think oh I
can't imagine Kanye showing up to the
Senate and help him craft some
legislation
he would not show up he like all the
other ones his bills would t be prior
are for the chloride to be perfect it
all be bill isn't perfect
I gotta update my bill we voted on it no
it's not done so uh there's some when
[ __ ] gets dicey starts getting it okay
lay it on it you don't have to agree
with Trump but the mob can't make me not
love him
we are both dragging energy he is my
brother I love everyone I don't agree
with everything anyone does that's what
makes us individuals we have the right
to independent thought that's a
perfectly fine statement yeah the last
sentence is yeah we have the right to
independent thought absolute [ __ ]
lutely right I can get behind that but a
dragon energy I would love phrase I need
that defined I need that used in the
sense beyond we are both Dragon Knight
exist that's all it is it's the new tire
love it's the new winning it's a new
tiger blood it's the most shy girl that
I'm not so ten years ago really less
than that Charlie Sheen had just like a
number of interviews or maybe was just
one famous infamous interview where he's
just he he had a couple of memes come
out of this interview one was winning
you know uh winning and I was like the
big thing that everyone repeated ad
nauseam like my wife it was like that it
was the new [ __ ] for a basically you
know it got old and memed death and then
the other was tiger blood like he has
this like one or a couple of interviews
where he just says really outlandish
[ __ ] and another one was like we're both
warlocks from like he's talking about
someone seeing someone else
both warlocks from Mars I'm paraphrasing
but like they like he just weirdly
poetic though at the same time weirdly
poetic but also narcissistic you know
coming it all comes back to this weird
narcissism and so one of the things that
came from this interview was he's
running on Tiger blood like he
references that okay and it's just one
like what the [ __ ] does that mean so
dragon energy is like this decades tiger
blood how your blood makes more sense to
me than dragon energy it's like what
what just enters like a meter that fills
that
like tiger blood makes more sense to me
if you like I've got blood it's extra
charge but dragon energy is like yeah is
that something that larger to gauge can
an evil warlock steal that a little but
if you're like a little oh definitely
you I think that happen in infinity war
that you will warlock creatures you will
kneel before yeah defne wars oh thank
you for that yeah all the [ __ ] let me
cut to the chase here
Oh notches watching and just donated it
better be huge I know cheers Cheers
notch notch I love you you cheered us up
he snuck in one of my twitch broadcast
over a month or two ago and and did the
same thing it was super nice he sent me
on a wild goose chase for the best salsa
in the game Newman's own salsa yeah
that's the best one and he can find a
better one and I went to like literally
five different grocery store trying to
find Newman's Own I couldn't find it
eventually I did I have to say not all I
love I love you and I appreciate you it
was a little it tasted a little tomato
paste II which I donation so I don't
know I mean I grew up in California and
I mean yeah yeah I don't know that
Newman
I don't know that new ones got it but I
I recommended one to you notch that I
hope you'll enjoy
Costco's got this unbelievable comes in
a 2 pack it's spicy I'm sorry Costco
Costco bro well it's not Costco brand
some sweet ok ok I'm sure some sweet
Mexican lady in her basement is just
like right what the giant wooden spoon
or something it's so good there's no
newman involved there's no old white and
involved in this process
it's that good just an old it has to be
what the giant wooden spoon yeah yeah
looking for a man yeah take her out on a
night if only there was someone right
just one night to Reese Park that love
but it's like anyway guys I don't know
the name of it but if you check Twitter
I tweeted it to him
let's get anyway Christ no I mean let me
just uh let me get to the really juicy
snotch and sauces and they have my dad
rock band not chin tonight so by the way
he goes into on all these like political
rants talking about how he loves Trump's
and then he drops this one now here we
go I'm nice at ping-pong that was my
favorite three I like that one's nice
because nice is such a funny ajik I'm
right it is you never described yourself
as nice at anything right but I actually
miss is that thing I actually really
like that sweet I'm gonna say like this
is a great I disagree with virtually
everything else this man says but I
really like that a lot I'm nice at ping
pong but it requires like I have to like
that is such a great tweet right below
it I'm nice at ding dong I think it I
think it was because it had a penis yeah
that's that's the best big ass just
balls yeah there's no one that wife that
float to the top
yeah why is that why Twitter and it is
Twitter so it probably Henry says I like
that a lot I'm not like I'm nice at
ping-pong like I can hold my own I got a
mean curve I gotta mean slice you know I
know there's something so wholesome
about not using like a traditional
adjective just drop it under nice it's
like so sweet I don't believe I don't
believe he's good at ping pong you how
much you think Kanye sits around
practices ping pong
well I have you seen his house he
probably has like Rose on Rose upon ping
pong tables like he pays someone to lose
against him but he's no I don't believe
that I think he is actually nice at ping
pong this is how I'd like to take him up
I'm pretty nice at ping pong I would
love to take him up on that I played my
dad may be good at ping pong growing up
I could I got all my own but I'll say
having following up on these very
divisive tweets that's that's a hell of
a way to yeah to bring it back down
that's quite a curve but it gets when it
gets worse it gets worse he takes he
takes a picture with the make America
great again hat right right it's signed
by Donald Trump
this was great I have to show this what
was that the Dilbert photos yeah the
Dilbert photo because
I'm not a fan of that guy but hey
whatever oh so so so the Trump gives him
a call-out Thank You Kanye very cool
it's an exposure condescending like very
cool Oh little guy yeah I didn't see him
saying those words it's like talking to
a kid very cool very cool but but of
course we also have to process the whole
he's not retweeting Connie's not
retweeting Trump [ __ ] no he's taking a
and it's not dream job he's taking a
picture of his phone screen so there's a
second [ __ ] phone yeah okay well
point out that it goes deeper than that
because it's actually a picture on
Instagram of the tweet best way to get
that screenshot out Kanye from from yeah
from media TKD I'm I don't even know
what that okay oh that's hilarious Kanye
god bless ya there are too many layers
he's not you should retweet that ice
well I need to take a screenshot I'll
post it on myspace and they did it
printed on a shirt yeah put that photo
on register that's just all I had to
share that one but then this is when it
gets really really really dicey is he
recently did a it's funny how much how
much [ __ ] got dragged over this like
chance the rapper tweeted out simply
black people don't have to be Democrats
trying to defend Kanye right and then
the next day he issued this like epic
apology of like how he got it so wrong
and he's so sorry like chance did yeah
that's sure they did well there's a
story internet this story heats up fast
okay first of all he says Obama was in
office eight years and nothing happened
in Chicago change that was that was that
was really heavy but this is when it got
really [ __ ] weird it was when he went
on TMZ seen this oh yes I don't think
people necessarily I stand what happened
last week with the great American make
America great again hat what are you I
know well it was really just my
subconscious it was a feeling I had you
know like people were taught how to
think we're taught how to feel we don't
know how oh that thing for ourselves we
don't know how to feel
for some people say feel free but they
don't really want us to feel free and I
felt a freedom and first of all just
doing something that everybody tells you
not to do I before we get to the
problematic stuff it does have a point
here right and I do we'll see what he
was trying to do
yeah like it is something good in a way
no I agree
just how like I agree like people don't
know how to think anymore you always
looking for someone to tell you what to
think about something and then you're
repeating it and like the what is a like
I I agree thought and more and I think
what he's doing of like as a Democrat or
or I guess black people are expected to
dislike Trump that's like part of the
culture I guess within their community
and so he's like well well let me think
about it for myself and come to a
collision for myself I agree in liberal
circles you're just expected to hate
Trump and a lot of people like it's one
thing to come to a conclusion and hate
him but it's another thing to just be
like oh I hate him cuz I saw it on the
TV
mmm right right like and it's fine it's
fine to hate him but like you need to
have reasons for that like that I'm
totally for that like yeah independent
thought is encourages it's it's smart
but we all know what's happening here
but then and this is when in free
thought goes wrong my boy he like you
know it's like so many rappers you look
at a video Snoop Dogg that's kind of a
bad supporting evidence by the way is
this like he's a meme and rap so why
should I hate him yeah with any getting
the office and I didn't love him like
Trump is one of raps favorite he's
immune rights not only we talked about
that before he was elected president
people in hip-hop big it was it was an
in thing to put Donald Trump in your
rhyme somewhere and by the way and
that's not endorsing his politics it's
just not I think he's a meme yeah bad
supporting evidence right so hold on
what what what is county is saying here
before like is he saying people would
always like mention Trump in yeah you
know lyrics even before he was president
just because he was such a character
yeah yeah like region feel like I hated
him before he was elected actually
elected I - man I thought I [ __ ] hate
that show I never watched it
like Trump really he might be a good
president I thought the apprentice
student that [ __ ] was annoying
did you watch shelf ever ye fault he's
right not to as hard as I could but like
you know but you drew mates you didn't
drive on the roommates right yeah just
like man I hate this [ __ ] old stupid
face of it's not right I can't stand him
yeah such a blowhard this face here that
be well he actually doesn't look too bad
there he looks he looks you know dare I
say presidential mmm there I stare
longer than them yeah yeah sorting that
[ __ ] things but I'm not just in hip-hop
I'm a black person a black communicating
but I'm not just I feel like one thing
is people try to minimize me to artists
hip-hop black community yeah I'm always
gonna represent that but I also
represent the world you hear about
slavery for 400 years for 400 years
that's not like a choice whoops okay
Yankee doodles he's like I mean right
you were doing fine dude up until I mean
you're making some good points and then
you didn't I wonder if he premeditated
that or that just popped out I think it
I think it popped out I think it popped
out because I think he's very I think
he's very um stream of conscience um
kind of stirred the moment like I don't
think he I don't think anything was
premeditated about this at all I think
it just happened and he just kind of ran
with it everybody came to work and
Connie I was just there like oh [ __ ]
here we go I got a new album right you
know like it's like we're we're mentally
in prison I like the word prison because
slavery goes don't to to direct to the
idea of blacks it's like 100 percent 100
percent Avery is blacks so prison is
he's slowly swallowing what he just
right blacks and whites being a one rate
yeah do you feel that I'm feeling do do
you feel that I'm being free and I think
it's this ugh I actually escaped I don't
think you're thinking anything I love
this guy this guy give him another job
and the reason why I feel like that is
because Kanye you're entitled to your
opinion you're entitled to believe
whatever you want but there
fact and real-world real-life
consequence behind everything that you
just said while you are making music and
being an artist and living the life that
you've earned by being a genius the rest
of us in society have to deal with these
threats to our lives we have to deal
with the marginalization has come from
the 400 years of slavery that you said
but our people was a choice frankly I'm
disappointed I'm appalled and brother I
am unbelievably hurt by the fact that
you have morphed into something to me
that's not real that's crazy that guy
came up with that that was I was
beautiful on Ellis I was hopped out from
a room in the back of head but the
insinuation that slavery in America was
a choice is pretty doesn't make it's
pretty [ __ ] real any [ __ ] sense I
mean like we were talking about it
before what Dan's like the slaves always
tried there was revolt they just like
they're like cool you want a right will
kill your family yeah Lilly rape your
child it took a [ __ ] Civil War yeah
yeah we took a lot to thin that [ __ ]
yeah not exactly a choice literally
almost tore the country apart
no well hey Kanye he's got a new album
coming out is what is so exciting what's
I wonder if it's gonna be good yeah I
was I was disappointed by that too
because you know what did you hear the
woopty doopty doopty i just heard I've
just read headlines actually I was gonna
be good it's gonna be this next verse
yeah listen up yeah well anyway look at
us we've been talking about his ass for
like a [ __ ] hour I know I know
well I mean hey it worked that's it
right that's exactly right it worked
that's if that was his endgame you know
I don't think that tricked into it
either I think we knew exactly what we
were doing by talking about it yeah no
no he didn't but I'm still not we're not
that he's saying the [ __ ] to promote his
album I don't think that's it I really
think this is what he danced pretty
junior I think it's genuine which is
like kind of kind of sad but I mean well
it's that either way that I know when
when there's no winning scenario
I don't think that he actually thinks
that I think you don't think I think he
like said it and now he's like trying to
commit to it right so that he's not he
doesn't have to apologize okay nobody
ever wants to apologize right right yeah
so now but anyway now this is a great
little twist since Howell and the Snoop
Dogg's cousin daz dillinger puts out a
gang hit on Kanye forcing him to
increase security and file a restraining
order doggy it's not that serious
no no not as oh [ __ ] a snoops cousin
yeah
this guy looks this guy looks stable man
that's what it look like he looks like
Beetlejuice from bog he's gonna put no
looking at the threat it looks like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm just trying to think
so he's I'm still kind of like hung up
on the fact that he snoops cousin now is
this now snoops responsibility I have to
wraps
talked to his cousin and be like hey
maybe not [ __ ] do that so or woman
thing or like is it like his eighth
cousin removed or there's cousin like
yeah right and you moved you guys look
into the relation and what was not
responsible that noop talk about dads
and his songs before I forget which Oh
Daz is you know never mind that has been
named dropped
well then snoop should definitely not
dogs call yeah thank you thank you
snip calls everyone cousin like but
definitely no that's not what it is
[Laughter]
O'Neil cousin to a degree you gotta get
your cousin Kanye there goes that theory
that's fine all right
yeah how about Bill Cosby raping a bunch
of people that [ __ ] gonna die
in prison
wait Bill Cosby don't what guilty guilty
guilty America's dad yes man that's got
to be one of the most like one of the
greatest betray
of all time abso-fucking-lutely like
there's a--there's a hard turn no one
like God before
Hannibal's like that now let's take it
back when did this really like who was
the whistleblower here was it Hannibal
during that set he made it like what it
is now right I think so you talked about
it like everyone knew but no one knew
before yeah I never before there was a
lot of accusers before right but there
was no social media it happened like
decades ago where that's a lot more like
hey this dude raped us right and then
Hannibal did his set like only a couple
years ago I'm gonna set went viral on ya
video Twitter video YouTube video bla
bla okay wonder if Hannibal like like
how he processed that afterwards yeah
like he disassociated with being there
so hey can you guys look up with
Hannibal ever made a comment about that
now that's a really good yeah crazy like
you you killed Bill Cosby dude yeah you
killed the man how damn I love I mean he
might deserve it
yeah he definitely did it well he'd know
he didn't kill the guy he just said a
[ __ ] word and then yeah yeah I'm sure
you set some cogs in motion at the Barry
Lea right no like a lot of I think I
raised a ton of eyebrows like I'm sorry
what like mine included I I mean like
not that I ever knew much about Bill
Cosby to begin with I never watched the
the Bill Cosby or the Cosby oh growing
up I predates yeah exactly yeah you know
we know what right you can't not even in
Israel same thing yeah you know
international star but apparently well
they tried him once and it was a hung
jury there was one person who wouldn't
convict him right and the second time I
guess there was one young black eye this
jury was telling a story and she kept
looking at him like trying to connect
with him because they they thought that
he might he might say not guilty and
apparently the story is that the one
thing that turned him was there's a
recording of a deposition from like a
decade ago in relation to some
accusation and what she admitted on
record to to giving some of his dates
quaaludes right and then having sex with
them yeah I remember that and I guess
that's the one thing that what the guy
was like you know the thing that he did
a couple women to sleep
gosh I wonder if we ever sprinkled some
date-rape in like jello yeah did he ever
get a truly arch with it like did he go
full villain good what do you think
about the fact that his wife's been
married to him for like 50 years then
stands by his side yeah no but there's
like no way she didn't know right well
she recently I think she's in the news
now because she recently said this is
mob justice like hey or two ago well 47
rape victims I think does count as a mob
that's right yeah yeah well three of
them are I think you only got no guilt
because it was a statute of limitations
yeah I think the rest of them have to
share that that feeling of justice but
you know what you know what makes me
think for sure it's real and there's
always like anything with Michael
Jackson is everyone's always like and
did he actually touch those kids or not
I have no doubt with Bill Cosby like
even when you saw those women there
relief after the verdict came I saw a
bit clips of them like such relief and
like oh so much like feeling that look
of vindication like there's no way you
could put that on I say yeah I say and
also he admitted to doing it haha
Moltres bad yeah it's I may have given
them a couple benadryl yeah man what am
I doing with this accent I'm working on
it all you're prepared by putting in the
rape couple of putting the chains oh man
it's very close it's very very close God
which one do I shoot I'm doing it yonder
bras be I'm not gonna very young I was
anyway that's good just man yeah he's so
[ __ ] old dog I feel like he plays
that old dog he does I feel like he
plays it up to get sympathy
he doesn't like nodding him know the old
he's like how old is he no he's like 80
something right he's on the low side of
80 I bet he that's great in the last
couple years though hold on
the thing is like 8080 I've met a lot of
eight-year-olds who you can have it
together eight yeah yeah yeah she was
written by the way how weird was it that
the news were watch they were live
streaming him driving away the whole
time did you see that drove bro well no
I liked the car that he was in it was
like a right Bronco chase yeah
wait what I didn't see that no after the
court whole thing when he was guilty
yeah
and he left it was in a car and they
were just driving away and all the news
were just streaming him drive helicopter
in live so it was it was oj all over
again driving home it's like they're
waiting for him to do something that's
kind of weird kind of sensationalizing
yeah I mean like he's already guilty
like it's already like stops and picks
up a woman one more pudding [ __ ] for the
road but like how they I don't know
right like yeah look at like Harvey why
see who was married to this fact this
I'm like you knew that he was was drunk
judge on Project Runway hmm god damn boy
god there's just a power thing they love
it the women they love it I just saw
begets another Netflix special that'd be
kind of cool though the prison yeah yeah
yeah Cosby's Netflix that everyone's
getting Netflix specials you know that
would probably be the highest-rated [ __ ]
oh dude he's got it together he's
playing it up didn't work that slot
candidate before being like hey hey hey
come on oh yeah that's you know me me I
think that maybe he was losing his
[ __ ] mind
right why would he want that's not the
move but not the move not at all
[ __ ] Fat Albert apparently he after
the verdict came in he stood up you guys
probably heard anything the prosecutor
was like let's send him to prison now
mmm no bail cuz he's rich and he's a
flee threat and he's a helicopter he
doesn't have a plane you [ __ ] yeah
right yeah
that's what he set up in court and
screamed he doesn't have a plane you
[ __ ]
thick of him he said I'm said right
right right right know about the
prosecutor he got up in scream right now
guilty big no-no so he's like at this
when he's got nothing more to lose you
know can you imagine like forget about
what he's done just imagine that the pit
of sorrow and despair his life has
become from being like the most iconic
American right yeah one of them or just
being [ __ ] worthless it'd be worse
than that not being worth right being a
most villainous person in in recent
memory from going from going from
America's dad to America's monster
honestly yeah that's he's not like not
like worse than worthless because at
least when you were worthless you're
forgotten about it is anything I've
forgotten right he's in the public you
know consciousness because of what he's
done what was his life before it all
came to light I wonder who it was every
day like fearing that because if if you
know you did that
what Lincoln's in decades in death no
way he probably thought he beat it yeah
yeah abso-fucking-lutely every night
beforehand yeah because all they gave
myself a quail in hell and three or four
decades like if you felt bad about what
you did you would have stopped after
maybe one decade he had not really right
not for now and the woman that actually
got to prosecute him because there's a
statute of limitation I don't know what
it is
but a lot of the old cases weren't able
to press charges with the one that was
able to was from like 15 years ago or
something like that's what he was
actually raping at the age of 65 yep
that's pretty good a [ __ ] girlfriend
what it's got a wife yeah but you can
get really that wasn't Jesus Christ
she's like look bill likey you're rich
you're old I mean Trump was banging porn
stars it's 60 something like right true
going the wrong road lately allegedly
true true that story isn't cracking me
the [ __ ] up like I love how incompetent
is a man and everyone out there
listening who supports Trump
you just got to admit that this is a is
an unbelievable trainwreck house but
like
it's like me the way that they've been
handling the story is just unmanageable
trainwreck first I don't know who she is
I never paid her any money then then
okay he yeah he paid her but I never
paid it back right and then Rudy [ __ ]
Giuliani right comes on Fox and Friends
is like Trump paid and back yeah so he
didn't break any finance reform and then
this morning Trump's like he's wrong I
never paid him well good is he sticking
to that bed at least at least if not Pat
Kelly saying well I did pay him back I
used the condom you're like at least
he's like finally like sticking to his
guns is that wrong how do they not get
the story straight on the highest level
possible get your [ __ ] stories
straight yeah Giuliani do you think that
they were on the same page when Giuliani
came on the show and was like he paid he
paid him back
he knows that plot real hard I know
what's the plot anymore yeah I don't
understand what they're cuz like I mean
I I don't give a [ __ ] if he's cheating
on his wife I assumed yeah doesn't
really bother my and it doesn't surprise
anyone either like no it's just that how
miserably organized and how bad of Liars
they are yeah more than what they named
yeah it's like dude you got to do better
than this right how did you run the
country if this is the rest of my please
drink me this is politics
yeah exactly Chicago
yes Chicago is a total you gotta trick
me we're also not voting for you vibe
that's the secret
yeah I got it straight guys should be
good at tricking us you guys hungry yet
what if I get too long away
are you serious this is a production
team that I love they read my [ __ ]
mind
I am so envious of what you guys like
the it's Wonder its Bunder bar I got an
uber helicopter for you guys it's like
when it came I got a cosplay you got the
helicopter bosses like 20k demolish the
parking lot I uh I owed the building
another 25 been on the books for a while
I don't know regrets though
here so Russia made headlines recently
they're actually a lot of people think
of Russia as like Oh kind of like back a
little backwards like second world right
but they've actually developed the first
Jerome delivered mail system that is
completely revolutionising the way that
mail is done in Russia so they're really
ahead of the game on that and here
here's actually the maiden flight of the
first delivery drone here we go
[Music]
such a great idea
I love this music really thousand so
that is when you put Walt acts in your
drag your right goes right that's a fun
everything's changing
did you guys hear I don't know if you
follow this about like loot boxes and
video games like it's well it became
illegal in in Belgium and um more than
one covers another your Netherlands the
Netherlands maids maybe you say what's
the chance of actually getting [ __ ] good
because that's Elena
yo China yes another ones I think also
just outright is banning them this is
gambling for kids yeah it's [ __ ] up so
[ __ ] that really is it really absolutely
is well what's the stipulation to make
it gambling like if you can sell the
stuff that you get in your boxes I think
it's more about the probability of cuz
I'm too much of an old man to like like
I know people sell knives and stuff and
counter-strike right yeah right in skins
and like I have a actual market value
right yeah yeah overwatch there's no
resale market you're not allowed to sell
items but it's just the kind of like
well first of all they don't even tell
you what are the odd wait is there a
whole Vegas you get the odds I'm very
old is this overwatch I have a loot loot
boxes and really great system yes okay
yeah so the distinguishing factor is to
that you can you can't buy it outright
you can only get it through the loop box
they lose my okay okay okay yeah that's
a motivating thanks god I really hate
that this is such a prevalent thing in
in video games cuz it's not fun it's not
it
it's worse than gambling it's like a
maybe maybe scenario right like I don't
and but it's become it has become the
game it's not a factor in the game it's
the game itself and that's like what the
[ __ ] what happened to like beating level
one like I I hate it right I and I just
avoid any and all yeah games that have
that as a selling point yes they had
better-looking skins but like every time
I see somebody with
skin on their gun or something like that
it looks [ __ ] stupid well Pub he has
stands out right like a not a good way
whoo it's [ __ ] purple Hello Kitty gun
yeah yeah but it appeals if no no it's
not for you but it appeals to a certain
type of person within a dick can
personality yeah I was like OCD
collector and logged a Lana collect
everything they want to feel immersed in
the game I guess it's like the new
version of fairy those are those rare
game like it like think think banjo
kazooie and like all those like
collectathon games platforming games
from like 20 years ago when you had to
not just beat the game but you had to
collect every coin every feather every
gem and all those I think this is just
the new form of platforming right if I'm
gonna be really [ __ ] geeky about it
it's like it's like introducing shopping
oh yeah you buy clothes that you don't
need right right like like that what
would you rather games be free cuz
there's like well there's like a free to
play yeah that's like supported by the
iodine by getting by than getting Luba
stuff I don't know it's it's complicated
I think no I would rather pay $50 for a
good full yeah the way it has worked for
decades like that's what I want like I
don't want to pay like yeah my friend
it's fine if you can buy it like and you
know you might just pay for something
but like I don't I don't like the
gambling aspect because you don't know
what you're gonna get yeah that part is
really fading and you can literally
gamble with those things on a website
where it like rolls right yeah that's
what those kids got in trouble for yes
yes go [ __ ] yeah yeah they had a [ __ ]
that was literally gambling for children
because you could sell that [ __ ] that's
crap um I think that just simply putting
the odds go is is goes a long way
agreed when you see when you actually
see your your probability and it's like
the equivalent of getting stricken by
lightning right oh wow gonna disclose
that like in counter-strike I swear to
god you buy a [ __ ] crate you get like
who god knows what what the probability
is
you drop three bucks and you've got like
one in a thousand right you know what's
going on there oh yeah
all right well god bless yeah we're
going in the right direction banning or
at least more more MORE
yeah more or that please more
transparency do I've been playing God of
War and like what a fun [ __ ] game
because it's self-contained yeah I don't
pay for like another extra tunic or
shield or the Hello Kitty gauntlet
really great though that would be great
I just know that Santa Monica studio is
if you're listening we would love them
more m16 game boy get my machine by the
way that game is sick
it's really good love it I grew up on
the ps2 and ps3 got Awards and this is
so it's very different the new one is
extremely different really I haven't
played the on any of the price they're
worth it like I don't I think they have
a collection for the ps4 I'm not sure
like I don't I don't want to get too
technical but they're worth checking out
just cuz there there's good hacking
slashers mmm it's really it's just
[ __ ] fun and this game is very
different from that but it's still fun
mm-hmm
this clip oh by the way I wanted to say
this Chris from one list one life we had
these guys on our cast oh yes the guys
got a [ __ ] he got a Mac you got it man
unbelievable yeah I don't know if it was
a result from the from day driving or if
it was just like a matter of time thing
you know I actually promised them on a
hand job in $5,000 but they they're
anonymous well not for long
they're there I welcome it I mean on a
non-person out they make me a promise
give me a boyhood mechanism by the way
okay this spoilers if you guys have you
guys all Cena infinity war yes yeah oh
so just a brief sanera did you see it
yeah she saw it we're gonna if you have
not seen it on please skip skip this
live which I do let me just say first of
all it's not stuff you really gonna show
me at it's not that bad it's just
hilarious
someone in the chest the Arrested
Development once someone in the chair
is saying that they did match with
someone else what does that mean with
the with the bone marrow what do you
know they did the they did the swab it
did this swab and they said I didn't
match with him but I did match with
someone know what and we'll be doing
that in two months
holy [ __ ] oh my god yeah dude that's
insane
pretty crazy Wow yeah yeah someone right
now they have that one's life here yeah
that's right man that's squiggles deduct
squiggles the duck god bless you nice
bragging yeah here's the deal I'm gonna
make you write for me you can have me
any way you want hey two squiggles this
dial or saving a literal human squiggles
the DA cool very cool I mean really
that's that's a beautiful thing really
happy
wait what I thought it was I thought we
drop it in hope they're not dropping
hard spoilers are we because I know I
won against uh no no okay here it is
here it is first of all did you guys
know it's the highest-grossing film of
all time
my buddy yeah I bet it's all its way to
be it's also the longest oh it's only no
it had embroidery [ __ ] hours all
ghosts I think it broke a record ready I
think the record was the fastest to a
billion yes yes and as of Monday evening
it hits 725 million that's it Wow don't
keep [ __ ] going I am in the movie
like I saw it on Friday Thursday or
Friday and I still can't stop thinking
about it like and this is the first time
a [ __ ] Marvel movie did this company
I downloaded a cam of it just so I could
watch a couple scenes that were stuck
with my service provider is Comcast IP
address once you ate something well
anyway there was a clip from of Mark
Ruffalo the guy who plays Hulk a year
ago oh I did see Ruffalo it's ruff ruff
Allah forget about a fake fan it's it's
a bit of a spoiler so don't click don't
watch for the next no you meant like
know what it is so [ __ ] precious I
have to watch it with you guys no no I
don't know this one um this is from a
year ago
nobody took it seriously because it
seems like they're doing a bit but when
you watch it now you realize can you
turn it up dan there's something funky
with the sound things just a quiet video
people are like counting looking at her
watch that and come back right when he
drops the bomb no are you is it up yeah
give it a shot no I can't come and say
no I wouldn't say too much but you can
say as much as me hey let me just say
this like every other Marvel movie it
doesn't end well for the superheroes oh
[ __ ] he's talking about
Don Cheadle so not down we know what cuz
it looks bad on him too he's like I
doesn't want you so - I'm so sorry I
talked to write over that it seems like
they're doing a bit what it does oh my
god what is wrong with him like how how
the [ __ ] no but nobody took this serious
no bail now I can't you know it's funny
I'm really trying hard to remove myself
from the knowledge of the movie and
trying to make that it's like the
optical illusion I'm trying to see the
old lady when I know that there's a
young lady I'm trying to see the old one
in the photograph I'm trying to figure
out the bit and it does seem like a very
genuine yet like yeah because they do
that joke ishe something wrong can we
edit this out the curb enthusiasm music
she's right he's right all I'm thinking
of right now is I mean like a he's right
and be the genuine dudeism
so mr. Cheadle is impossible to miss so
good so I can't I'm sure I can't get
into sketch mode yet you know this
ability I went to see the [ __ ] movie
it's one of my favorite things ever I
want to see it again
that's true and marvel it doesn't end
that well somebody always buy so it gets
really badly wait till you see this next
one everybody to do what is wrong Don
Cheadle wonderful actor he's not that
good no that's a genuine like like oh
stop stop stop stop stop it's like it's
like when everyone does that what's uh
what's spider-man Tom Hall and Tom
Holland is that his name then at the
venom no no no no that's Tom Hall is
like well the young spider-man in this
franchise Tom Holland his is infamous
for revealing spoilers and stuff in
interviews and so usually it's like
Benedict Cumberbatch who does it who has
to Don Cheadle's role and says like or a
lemon hard not just not to spoil a movie
oh my yeah well yeah you'd think right
can I say if I have a funny anecdote
forever spoiling a movie is known as
Shaunie in my family my brother's name
is Shawn and he has the best spoiling
story of all time I he's seen he's here
by the way he's in the chat hey my
brother
Shawn so the sixth sense which is like
the most horrible film of fun right so
he's seen it I'm going to see it with
him once and he goes there's one scene
we're all in a swing the kids on a swing
and he turns to me he goes you noticed
that the kid doesn't have a shadow or
something stupid okay I understand
exactly everything now and I and by the
way the worst part was that he did have
a shadow I wasn't like a movie like it
was but then so I get super angry then
we go back home my dad hasn't seen it
yet I'm super excited and I'm and he's
like how was the movie and I'm like
Shawn ruined the [ __ ] movie for me
midway through and he goes I didn't even
tell you that he was dead at the end I
didn't even tell you that he's dead and
then my dad was like you oh that's some
shining right that's Shawn Inge the best
show I love it they happen well they
sure get your brother to do like
apks for the next infinity why not like
show him the movie beforehand interview
him on all the late shows right but
I guess the point is that some people
just I don't know they can't put a lid
on it I think he I think his
justification is he's actually genuinely
excited about this movie and he's like
dude you should see so this is like okay
this was posted on July of last year
you thought see the next one you should
see I think he's just genuinely excited
I think especially Tom Holland like the
spider-man is so excited about these
movies like he they're so I was looking
about good actors or fans of the Mahr
the moral or they almost don't realize
what he's saying
it's almost being like a hyperbolic but
it's actually but it's actually spoiler
territory yeah Bobby people do we lose
off the stream by pulling this up that's
interesting question I feel like
everyone's seen it you don't get a
billion dollars for weeks you know what
I want to see it again well I'll give it
to you you pick up a couple of things
okay this I don't think this is a
spoiler this is just a cool Easter Egg I
read online and I was skeptical about
this Easter Egg until I saw it the
second time and it's [ __ ] true it's
absolutely true I love this so the
directors the the Russo the Russell
brothers the so Dave you should I so
these these brothers that directed if
any more they also did Civil War and
they also directed back in the day
they've directed a number of episodes on
Arrested Development huh yeah that's
quite a repertoire quite a reprimand
filling it to the biggest franchise in
cinema so they in in civil war they
snuck in during the big airport fight
scene with every all the Avengers
they're on the Torah the we call the the
term AK the tour magne mack tarmac Jesus
Christ the tarmac in the distance it's
subtle but you can clearly see the Bluth
staircase mobile the stick their car in
the background as like a little homage
it's from a restaurant that is the show
from yeah there you know back in the day
so an infinity war these guys were able
to sneak in and even better
Arrested Development Easter Egg that's
off the [ __ ] charts and this is not a
spoiler I really don't think it's a
spoiler because it doesn't have anything
to with the plot well you can't top we
already ruined the mood well at some
point they end up on the collector's
planets you know as you guys know and
like that's not a spoiler and of course
like the the we've already had an excuse
to do the Howard the Duck Easter Egg
which was like a big thing in one of the
older movies there's a split it's
literally like two seconds long there's
a shot of Gomorrah on the collector's
planet behind her is a tube containing
[ __ ] Tobias the never-nude that no
ice are you freaking clue Dobby seeing
this yeah I know yeah he's blew it out
like the because of because of the the
Blue Man Group that whole are my knees
would heal himself when he when he blow
there's gotta be a better way to say
that and like and and it's there and I
[ __ ] it took me everything to not
lose my [ __ ] in the theater because like
you had like her you saw right away well
until I watched the illegal copy that I
have in my are dress how was that I you
know it was good quality I don't endorse
they're not hurt donate 5 bucks it's not
it's not an arthouse film I got a movie
pass [ __ ] off exactly when I was in
Israel I used to can vids cuz it was
kind of like the only choice sometimes
but I could never [ __ ] watch cams
I just they're always so shitty huh mmm
I watched a Kim the worst cam I ever did
yeah was a cam of South Park guys
Broadway Book of Mormon yeah I watched a
cam of you like a Mormon that makes
sense like I could watch ruin to play
for me because it was so bad ruin the
play all right don't cam a Broadway
that's I'll say in this cam of infinity
were that I have there is a [ __ ]
dudes head and you can hear the audience
laughing at that Oaks s throughout the
entire so like it came with the
experience of video absolutely because
you raised had that option got turned on
like the audience
it's just something [ __ ] head in front
even some [ __ ] putting his feet up on
the scene you being that [ __ ] guy
baby holding a phone
yeah like honestly pouring out for that
guy like like having the stamina to do
that for three hours well back in the
day they used to have to have camp are
actual camcorders in the [ __ ] mini
VHS it was like a coat over it or some
[ __ ] well cuz I still that I wonder
there's got to be something he's
probably got a monopod do you guys want
to UM camp some videos for fun and just
see what it feels I think we should go
to infinity war I'm nice why don't we
see who gets the best kick that's what I
was gonna well put them all on eBay I'll
call it the Ethan version the Eric
version the Jackman and then you guys
can all vote afterwards we'll see who
has the most right and then whoever wins
you can sponsor us to go rip off your
next favorite film yeah well make a
business out of it franchise that's a
win win win in my book guys on the way
and the the trick is we do this all in
Brazil ripped on Brazil like to our you
know it's sorry we made it we made a
video a couple years ago yeah the those
like the worse for some reason we just
could editing I don't even know how much
that made it into the final thing not a
lot he was like not a second cousin
would spend we spent like a bottle and a
half of wine [ __ ] on Raziel do I
need to pee yeah there's beets outside I
want to pour stiffer drink because let's
be honest yeah this is come on it's
sugar water
it's sugar was I know I've got the
beginning of a buzz but I want to make
some mistakes here today I got some I
got some absolute just waiting to be
drunk that's like I wasn't gonna just
spike in the punch a little bit even
better you know him YUM so I'm just
gonna run the bathroom guys we'll be
right flipping back where's this young
thing coming from alright guys don't
frickin leave cuz I mean what the hell
are you doing you're already watching
this on a Friday afternoon I doubt you
have anything better to do yeah just
drink with us guys grab your peanut
butter you later just grab a drink movie
I won't be dropping spoilers for
affinity wars throughout there's no way
to anticipate
every $10 tier of donations get a new
spoiler Superman [ __ ] dies dude sorry
but he does get paid for it yeah it's
like my one of my favorites behind
Batman and his movies in the past decade
have sucked the hardest Superman movies
ah Kevin Spacey was a pretty good lex
luthor though in Superman he was wrong
he really was another me ya member that
[ __ ] you're the man now right yeah I
thought you were just passionate I
didn't know you're doing impression oh
no no that's a lot no that and then it's
funny nobody remembers that Superman
movie nobody remembers that soup that
was the one that was my favorite isn't
that funny the new ones are such dog
[ __ ] it makes me wanna [ __ ] die an
emo [ __ ] yeah who [ __ ] cares it's
magic if you guys tuned in we're gonna
be watching Man of Steel followed by a
rib it was on FX earlier so I came that
all right we'll be right back goddamn it
don't don't you go anywhere we are back
from our break I had a couple slices had
poured a drink and quaalude it our
intern it's been a fun time man to blur
it's a bit of a blur man I've got I've
got some good stuff here let's see yeah
what's your what you got Ethan what do
we got lay it on us
let me fine boys club I have a ton of
[ __ ] here but I want to pick out the la
creme of the leigh crop is that another
try not to cringe challenge god I have
that kind of is fantastic if you want to
do that I mean I'm set up I don't wanna
know your way your way there you go Oh
Noah Abdul stalker on American Idol
season said oh is this a [ __ ] real
it's kind of interesting cuz it starts
as a joke but then you the line is
blurred between like is should the sky
be removed or is he doing a gag
enjoy
it's very quiet den that shirts not
doing him any favors I'm gonna say that
shirt needs to be a little bit longer
but hand buttoned up more like I don't
know it looks like a toddler I've got
the level cranked here do you have any
volume on I'm out I'm out of juice that
face is unbelievable that low boy off
the thumbnail right there that is yeah
most definitely
pucker up buttercup this guy just [ __ ]
old ladies to be killing they don't say
no which apparently there's a market for
so [ __ ] damn it all right this is a
bed so right there's a point where
you're like oh this is a bit yeah funny
but but not really at what point do you
say oh this isn't a bit anymore that's
funny
[Music]
Peter Falk this is where I say he's
getting too close
no I think it's a bit I think in the
entire thing I know it is but I would
not take any chances
it's a bit um what's the comedian's name
Andy Kaufman ness is that his name yeah
yeah like the guy from Dan your voice is
louder no God God freezes me because
that's the thing that Andy would oh he
would take the joke too far and then
keep pushing it I feel like this guy's
kind of titling his own right sure I
like using what I'm strutting about is
like you're not drinking coca-cola right
now why you lying to me about with those
coke cups
okay sorry certain oh well though it's a
big sponsorship they like they were
synonymous it was like peanut butter
jelly American Idol and coke like that's
I you know it's clearly water but like
you know bothers me when you go to the
movies recently when you go see infinity
Wars for example whatever you watch it I
can did it they always do this [ __ ] by
the way I wanted to do is I'm not gonna
do that
buzzing bit like do it I was gonna spoil
the whole movie at the joke I was like
you know how to Monica yeah chats
already do but they do they do this
thing where they advertise coke right
before the movie stars right and it
bothers me because I cannot go buy a
coke yeah yeah why you do very creamy
and frothy and like it's the cosmos the
copyright for the movie stars yeah
please be quiet all inside of like a
beautiful coca it's like what are you
trying to real like I can't go get a
coke now you know what my jam used to be
Cherry Coke and movies like I couldn't
it was something trigger I could well no
nothing happened it's just like I
couldn't see a movie and not drink
Cherry Coke that's just like my movie
drink so it's very like still [ __ ] with
it not so much anymore but that's just
like oh that's just my religion but like
no I [ __ ] love please don't laugh at
that but yeah it's just um it's very
it's it's very pavlo nyan pavulon e'en
right you know you just so it is very
misleading do the coke [ __ ] 15 minutes
prior to the movie let give me a chance
yeah like during the coming attractions
before the trailers yeah eighteen
trailers I see before the trailer you
get enough [ __ ] like like hey drew
coke but right right before the movie
starts you've got like this incredible
visual systemic air dropping into a coke
and right all this shit's like dude it's
very app is easing me
it's very apathetic embarrassed I get
angry about is every time you don't I
yell oh I always sure I said I can't get
a [ __ ] up now awaits the opportunity you
know that's when you leave and you ask
her like hey yo Dawg and you just like
fill me in on the first like 10 minutes
like like a video next to you no
spoilers but a lot happens in the first
10 minutes of Infinity Ward how much
pressure is that I hate that when
someone leaves and then you have to fill
them in that's what happened I always
lie Aaron pulls that [ __ ] on me
sometimes but what can you say it's
always like he just [ __ ] went he got
a bar he just met in saga I think that's
fine in Thor and star-lord just [ __ ]
kissed for like 3 minutes uninterrupted
one common men it's that's what Thanos
he uses his gauntlet for it just to make
the dudes kiss it's really do that we
were shot lightning the reality's
nipples and called him his new boyfriend
by the way either one of those three
would would probably never touch a coke
and their whole [ __ ] life I believe
Randy would Randy's to be a big boy he's
on that kick now you still looking kind
of big in this yeah these are all vodka
tonics well hold on I will fight before
the other two bakit yeah yeah can I joke
about the text you got okay yeah cuz I
was just gonna say oh my when we were
going for the break I well let me read
it watching criticism was not lost on us
I guess this is was when we went from
talking about Kanye to talking about
Cosby he texted me too much about
Blackman sounding racist they just
wanted to look out for me make sure the
pen too so you know we didn't want to
overstep our back in the news what is it
it was literally big dude but what I was
thinkin was like oh man we're talking
about Randy's going to die see now right
right right
I think we get off the black a little
bit of a steerage that he was trying to
give us he was worried that maybe there
was a third get back to the whites
yes well iíve got my Brazil jokes in my
hip pocket well I think maybe that's
safer because they don't have the
Internet they have black people though
Oh shame on of them yes stay in Brazil
oh yeah well you know we were talking
about [ __ ] downloading Kansas stuff
you know I'm in in Cuba they have this
thing called the program which is these
USB sticks because they don't have like
sound so Big Brother ass it's just a USB
stick filled with like every season of
every TV show right much of movies and
like cam movies and just know a guy like
you like hook me up with the mailing
this month's program yeah for like
30-something box that's sick weird yeah
I mean not weird that's an interesting
idea what you do for your buddy when he
lives out in the middle of nowhere yeah
yeah the program yeah let me get you the
program man but that's like all of Cuba
that's a good place to pirate I'm
surprised security let him approach the
desk yeah it's all they had to be in on
the bit though the judges because they
wouldn't do that they would not let a
person absolutely not absolutely not so
it's all a bit you just you just debunk
this I'm sorry I just told you Santa's
not real the emperor has no clothes but
that's that's what's happier sin right
there's why they would not let me get
like that [ __ ] clothes yeah yeah my
my stocky if I were the stalker they
might have a gun trained on them they
don't have to get tall but Eric it was a
simpler time guys here any second now
try not to cringe oh hell yeah what's
this oh god what another black guy very
cringing all your dad it's well anyway
it's not about Kendrick is about a white
guy that comes why just become like a
race war like air time black and white
people go but it's about the sort of fan
gets on stage and like [ __ ] it up and
he's white
I've seen this by the way you got some
he say you want to go bro he's got a
great laugh yeah I love Kendrick he's
like my favorite artist yeah in a long
time hmm God just throwing that up be
serious don't go sneak challenging you
can't be okay okay then come up here he
said it's not really a challenge he said
you just want to write come on through
it's very nice of him yeah I can do they
let anyone else like to let's own on
stage sometimes this works out really
actually it works out well when they're
in on it
okay when they know that the guy is like
why are you ruining this no no this is
probably legit I'm sorry what's up no no
no I'm not buying what you're saying no
I'm not buying about went okay no wait a
minute wait a minute Michael Buble had a
very big viral video from years ago
where like some kid came onstage and
he's like alright and then of course the
kid kills it and has like the voice of a
name do you think that's perhaps the
[ __ ] lady's Michael Buble who's a
Buble boy who's Buble why you're clearly
not a 39 year old you know box with the
Buble come with that name he's like mr.
Christmas dude boo-boo Michael Buble has
like okay you know like he's first off
he's I don't know hit singles like home
he looks like a boob let me go
that's a bad example he also sounds like
I just haven't met you yet like that's
Buble he also does like all these
Christmas albums then kind of like the
old Sinatra big band vibe but he's like
kind of like he brings it back for like
a modern age hmm he's just like a he's
he's a big singer he's a bit of a Buble
he's a bit of a Buble if I add is there
an accent over the e in Buble or is it
just the same I I think there is I think
there honestly is an accident but I
could be very fun drunk
otherwise it's bubble boom ooh blob not
as good the accents confirmed hey thank
you thank you that's what that's why
that's why we got here well I had any
rate yeah it takes a lot of balls first
of all to accept that challenge
absolutely they are really good yeah
yeah are not in on it whatever you
[Laughter]
damn you're getting on stage with
Kendrick bro you better be good by year
as Fox it's all you
Kendrick didn't hand you the mic good
give me a beat don't give me a beat give
me a peak ice like he owns the band tell
you though I ain't gonna go okay let me
just see what you got cuz you only never
know us this is the people I'm good at
night which case I beat the beat okay
give me something good he said need a
beat that's how we go stop talking give
me some very good no no no okay you
feelin fine in the tough guys you can
start it out over death I can see the
end of the videos coming up real quick
it's your cue buddy
this shit's taken years off of my life
Kendricks love in there it's gonna shoot
like it is vo man how is he not
physically cringing he's loving it he's
like y'all shout out to everyone who
says I suck right now no one's saying
that ya know one thing that no one saved
me yeah kick him off that's how you say
oh man he's looking for help he's
looking for lights out his [ __ ] all
right thank you this massive bodyguards
like get the [ __ ] right they probably
because that's out there accident and
now it's the last time Kendrick ever let
anyone on his stash ever
goddamn when you got a set of precedent
I guess yeah yeah that's that's the
paint he looks amazing by person though
like that was kind of brilliant in a way
it's like maybe they're not saying he
sucks with you like damn he's amazing
yeah oh so they like so here's what they
do they [ __ ] pay someone and oh yeah
it's real to be bad Jax polluter receipt
closet yes
what was that pit bulls thing thank you
oh my god we need to read to a pit bull
lyrics okay let me pull up well that's
just something that when you love you
every time [ __ ] yeah do you guys want to
see a good one by the way a great one
the ace what are you guys [ __ ] tiny
what is this know what it is is a
theater yeah really
where's the audience if I said the a/c
babies tiny what do you think about
gives me everything is big yeah give me
everything give me what like the this
song by pitbull are you familiar with
that one I I think not working yeah yeah
Oh better yet know the time squared take
a picture of me with a Kobach he just
rhymed code up with Kodak damn right cuz
he's pitbull he does what he [ __ ] line
I guess
well now where's my bounce I can't ever
do my mouth it he's K where's my [ __ ]
mouth I'm panicking I need control what
we're criticizing it we're talking about
it which is uploaded by the artist
himself Jordan Alexandra isn't that
[ __ ] dough food 73 million I kind of
want the imagery though yeah I want to
the mere video no I don't nobody likes
the lyric video nobody do the songs fire
what do you know about good music yeah
yeah yeah the official link bro the
lyrics are so fired they need a [ __ ]
okay
me me not working hard Yeah right
picture that with the Kodak [ __ ] yeah
and then and better yet go time visit
and take a picture of me with the Kodak
that's that doesn't that mr. pitbull
with all due respect giant fan love you
work not a rhyme that's a real go visit
Times Square and find pitbull to take a
pic I'm waiting and Times Square took my
life from negative deposit I thought I
thought that'd be like a fun like
usually when people do that they set up
for a pun like took my life from a
negative to a positive
and then like something like you know
photographic development expects you to
know that but and there's no there's no
say you know just so you know you did
that you did that thank you
like what what like something about
Photoshop imagery no and like it never
[ __ ] happens look at this run yeah
night I will love you tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
way hopes
oh yeah it's my [ __ ] that's right this
is my favorite pit bull snot by the way
sexy [ __ ] had the fire pit bull did
everything I think you just hate Jude
great pit bulls okay here's what I want
to do I'm gonna go pit bull and I'm
gonna sort by viewcount let's see was
his most mrs. Jennifer Lopez one point
two Billy Jesus Christ favors number two
Syrena reign over me that sounds like
the name of a gay porn was that for the
9/11 movie with Adam Sandler oh right
bringing over me with Don Cheadle yeah
yeah yeah yeah 9/11 movie right there
was there no I know exactly were talking
about yeah there was called rain over
man Christ
don't worry stoneware I'm shaving you
know but they're too late you're making
a weird joke no no this is I the movie
okay yeah really I don't say in their
best work since the cobbler
the 17 very 911 H to me this just wait
hang on I need to pump the lyrics to
this always always mr. worldwide oh my
god dude have some respect for the
people that that perished on that day
mr. worldwide mr. oh yes like I don't
think there's any connotation with the
the the classic Don Cheadle Adam Sandler
movie right over me but that'd be really
analyze it was the plot of that Milligan
claim well I never stopped I followed
his wife and I just saw posters I just
will say anymore
yeah yeah they do know they still do
he's got a look
[Music]
aah aah I know Julian's the new million
yeah apparently
get on what they did I do not know the
song really this is really managed to
one of his top head I parted everyone
really bro how you gonna [ __ ] write a
brand deal into your first line that
just shows Skyy Vodka oh my I said
volleys the new vodka
wait well I know I saw the vodka is that
in the actual lyricism boley's a new
vibe of my whole life
oh my god wrote that into the first line
oh my god smart guy bro volleys the new
vodka never have I ever had a single
drop of volley I've never ever seen it
in the store never heard it so you're
nothing eleven okay so still enough for
nada I've always liked dippin dots the
supposed ice cream of the future that
has not yet been the ice cream of the
future yet house only your's like how
does it freeze their thoughts because
yeah cuz they're like they're ice cream
like moleculus into little I say I love
dippin dots yeah but like overpriced
well obviously but where do you hold on
that's why I failed where do you where
do you buy dippin dots well the only
that you can get it the theme parks
that's right no that's right yeah
they're like yeah it's 30 bucks for a
[ __ ] fine I want to dip in the stew
be the ice cream in the future but I got
a tip but it's not it has been billed I
don't ice cream with a future for the
dot man personally he's back there I
sent you a good bendrix Lamar fan video
can you watch that it's not ok are we
over this I don't think we can top
volleys a vodka timber no that's that's
really great that billions the more days
the new 30 and baby - no it's not sorry
oh yeah
all he's doing is singing like Rachael
Ray yeah talk show titles I'm freaky
baby I'm gonna make sure that your peach
feels peachy baby
no [ __ ] broads I like when women
sexy classy sassy powerful yes they love
me to get the middle nasty ow
this ain't a game you'll see Dale Mooney
uh-oh the whole Spanish sorry guys just
let forties in there anyway
never apologize Bodhi wait bodis the new
vodka what what does that mean I think
that's a typo that's got to be a [ __ ]
typo which is a crime in the next verse
that's right yeah a new brand deal it's
a call from vote what the [ __ ] is this
that's so sad enough a pitbull okay so
my new Twitter bio is Foley's new vodka
yeah out of my mind you sent me
something eula yeah man this shows off
the rails at this point but the problem
is your heart I mean what I love about
the podcast is like once you get past
two hours anyone who's still watching
all bets are off the writers are the
company any people guess they're at work
and work is boring that's true
and we're here drinking sometimes I feel
the pressure like oh man oh this is good
but it's like at two hours are you
better
we're making new problem we're not
damaging any lives better creating
problems right Eli there better not be a
black person in this video it's not dad
stop
did he text you yeah I'm not gonna
donate no oh I wanted some bits from
your dad okay
this doesn't look fake but I mean I
don't know I don't know she she looks
like she's gonna do a great job it could
be a plan I'm not gonna lie it's it's
kind of she's really put together nope
what if she doesn't date exact same rap
that that last dude it's like it's the
same way
[Music]
I don't know you are do you think
Kendrick would lie I look he's too real
right now yeah but you gotta put butts
in those seats you know I'm Sam so
anything ourselves concert ticket this
is okay
by the way if you're a fan this isn't
that hard it's not that remarkable that
guy failed so bad he was doing his own
[ __ ] like what way like here's a song I
wrote guys I get enough of this on the
sunny this [ __ ] concert that's why I
need that beat yeah well she's just
she's singing the classic that can get
down with that backup vocals oh my god
[Applause]
she's a fringe yeah I like seeing the
house even if they watch it I don't
think it's not there's actually a better
one that I thought this was it I don't
think it's fake that one's definitely
not fake
they're all not fake I think it's
[ __ ] fake dude everyone in the front
row knows the lines I want to get like a
baby I sure if I ever do like a concert
and I get my music career going I want
to get a baby out of the audience and
have it come up and perform hey do you
know the lines yeah okay these little
babies I guess what neck or something
stick a mic up to it and the baby kills
it thank you
big man this was real this baby
tossed it into the crowd that's easy
five million views God all right let's
move it on you guys want more cringe
hell yeah later please Judge Judy this
this is just this is short and sweet
this is powerful all right hold on well
I don't want to spoil it because I
haven't feared are you gonna say it's
fake yeah cuz I'll walk down
oh no no no quite the opposite is this
the one where he [ __ ] admits to no
yelling okay okay okay both of yours is
that in your home or condo apartment
that was in the basement on my trailer
no I'm just kidding oh it was my home
damn that oh man tough crowd huh ooh
that's a toughie not even the cricket
thing save this but not even him cracked
a smile not even he yeah I think he
might have admitted this yeah your plate
yeah I mean this is probably maybe the
the most bomb any joke ever delivered in
the history of man basement on my
trailer no I'm just kidding oh is my
home oh that delivery is crazy now L
know the whole website if this is an
Andy Kaufman task performance of this
guy's the real genius right right but
something tells me it might not be what
have you look at this deadpan delivery
it is very very deadpan believe I have
to watch this again yeah he looks like
he took like eight minim quaaludes
beta-blockers before coming in here the
calmest dude in the world wait what is
it beta blocker it's like a performance
enhancement drug for people who do like
we're gonna do I mean I think it's meant
for like blood pressure there's a go
heart medicine some sort but what it
does is it calms you down when you're
gonna go perform in front of a crowd if
you get like anxiety really have you
ever tried that I have taken it for a
job interview once did it work it worked
I guess I mean there might be a bit of
it you get the job I did yeah that I was
very calm for it to beta-blocker yeah
can we get some beta boy like ask anyone
if you know anybody does like um like a
piano audition or like they're getting
into like Juilliard or something like
that and they have to go up in front of
these people gonna be [ __ ] so nervous
you take a little beta blocker and
what's the block what's a beta if it I
think it blocks your fight-or-flight
response to be more just like in the
middle like you don't yeah you know
feeling like your body's like [ __ ]
trying to cringe its way out of the
situation and you don't buck up because
you're nervous and you OD on that [ __ ]
definitely I would imagine you get the
OD on anything this is what happens is
your point
this guy od'd on beta-blockers yeah got
a little new fasting with the judge no
fighter flight in this man left god that
was in the basement on my trailer nice
high no I'm
just kidding Oh is my home
someone in the back loved Ireland on the
wrong foot mr. Russell I'm going to
assume that you who had wanted to get
off on that so we're gonna start again
okay okay he looks like the dude from
Silicon Valley yes definitely got
definitely it Robbie down G jr. full
interview stop Jr I didn't say that my
favorite Avenger reading but now what we
have is is a lot of good material for
fan art checking your subreddit out okay
there was a lot of reports reporting
every one hour and hour three I don't
want to pry so you don't talk about it
that's fine but what you said to the New
York Times once was it was about it was
after your incarceration and you said
you can't go from a two thousand dollar
no else Margaret this guy interviewing
him gets in trouble all the time for
like out of setting up these miss for
that you're supposed to be talking about
my [ __ ] movie tell me about your
father did you so right and it's like
whoa
so anyway he's on the same crack news
team as you recognize this class act
that's the lady who did know now for
interview of Jordan Peterson Oh in her
face they're on the same crack team man
they've got to get some better wait what
floor I'm I'm well it's the Jordan
Peterson interview this lady did an
interview of Jordan Peterson to promote
his books but she came like with all
these real I mean it was really viral
she knew extremists she was just out to
get him in short okay super rude well
super accusatory I mean not a good
interview and her handle was great but
what's the what's the saying like
something over something's the
together two birds of a feather birds of
a feather something of a Samba bird
something of a feather with feathers at
channel 4 and yeah that dude has as an
interview with Samuel Jackson and oh no
maybe just with Tarantino but I think
with Samuel Jackson too where he talks
to Quinn Tarantino he's like but do you
think your movies need to be violent
don't you think you're encouraging
violence Tarantino who's always looked
he looks like he's always on like a
[ __ ] yeah it's like I don't care you
see yeah terrible Tarantino yeah Cosby
as they're in theater like to do it
I love seeing temperature that's a good
interview Tarantino just like he's like
I don't care pull that up uh in Dan I
want to watch that this is great a lot
of drugs and probably know if it was him
but I remember someone accusing him of
of making violent content and he slam
dunk dunk yeah so this guy from an
episode of cops probably the most tragic
failure of all time to explain one's
behavior is a wonderful train wreck that
gets worse with every passing soften I
love it already
prostitution activity in these hotels
what's up buddy hey good everything okay
yeah oh what's your name sir Faisal okay
what are you doing here sir nothing much
I'm just looking for my friend what's
your friend's name
my friend name is Bryce is he staying at
the hotel here no he can't be meet
someone over here so I'm just here to
pick up my wallet because I forgot my
wallet in his car you don't have any ID
on you I do step out okay bring your
hammer on your back and where's Raj yeah
he told me was gonna come back okay
what's in the bag it was on your lap
whoa right into it where the plastic bag
that fell off your lap no he's got a bag
of meth first it falls off his lap and
then I fell asleep and then
woke up with that on your lap yes is
that maybe something that could help you
fall asleep or no no no no your pulse is
through the roof no I'm guessing you
don't know just nervous is your ID in
this uh wallet that you said your friend
had I can see a driver's license you can
pull it up okay and this is not yours I
don't know what is this it's almost like
a classic like Abbott and Costello it
really is yeah it really this is like a
modern who's on first deal right
methamphetamine with driver's license
was suspended in he's also got a warrant
out of Nevada County have you used drugs
before okay well you're gonna go to
court with the items that you were found
in possession of huh your story's still
a little scattered do you have anything
else illegal on your socks shoes
anything like that
no okay I know you're high okay I smoke
weed you're higher than you think
no no it's because when I woke up I seen
the lights and stuff and I seen you guys
I got nervous
I had a monster drink I don't know took
your head down a little bit okay your
tongues pasty-white about this guy's the
best oh man he wants to get out of this
real bad yeah
not that I blame him but uh well I
wonder if you look up kebab on like
WebMD it's like pasty mouth basically
white tongue use your phone today yeah I
was you need to rush who Susan Susan
you have snow and weed baby and we can
party a little like if I can Christopher
guest's teen right here this is
wonderful no baby 104 an hour Oh only a
hundred for an hour so it sounds like
haggling on her price dude I'm like
that's all I gotta say I mean I don't
unless you want me to make up stuff
absolutely not writable oh my god detect
that's what sold it for me the [ __ ]
text messages do that can they just look
through your phone I'm pretty sure this
guy incriminated himself so bad that
police really had no [ __ ] reason
question it buddy even if you're some
interesting how did they record it for a
show is that I'll do that
skull baby is there a really good
question is there something we're like
if they sign a release there they're
able to like get some sort of plea deal
or if he's just like that's the most you
really walk out let my ass out or no cuz
on judge judy when when you know payment
is is decided on whatever the show pays
both parties right so like it's not real
court they're getting paid um like
talent fees to be on it I wonder if cops
is the same or it's like hey man I know
you got busted with prostitute meth coke
your jog thousand bucks for the really
yeah for you go sign this release will
get you out of prison a little forever
and infamy on YouTube mine let's see oh
here's the interview with Quentin I just
looked it up on cops it really is the
people just sign release but yeah how
did they convince people to sign a
release that seems like a like well why
would you want to put that on the
internet if you're like a lowest moment
in your life right take that and apply
it to [ __ ] To Catch a Predator like
hey you want to say unless they walk
past the sign outside that was like this
premises film right
but how do they how did they get
permission for catch a predator I think
there might be some some legal
arrangement made where they're like if
you sign this will something something
they never believed her feather how
could it ever be worse maybe it's just
like no rocket they're a pedophile
they're like barely humans there are
some of them that are not even illegal
are you I'm it no not at all your honor
he's a pedophile right he's not even
human
watch this episode of prime-time
television right I do want to watch this
let's see oh it is the same guy [ __ ]
this guy he's so smug - he talks like
he's all sophisticated yeah you could
say English act like I'm just here to
promote my movie [ __ ] right right and
of course it's you know Barbara Walters
the thing that's [ __ ] up the same
thing happened in Jordan with channel 4
it's like you're going and talking about
your book that's the expectation you're
not going in you're doing like 20 a day
there's no expectation that there's yes
there and it's not the right place
either come with like a serious
conference with your gotcha quite
mountains or not it's a short interview
can't how are you gonna ask a question
but I don't know your dad and the past
and you don't know how they're gonna
chop it up after the fact exactly I
really can't even go into it what made
Quentin Tarantino lose his cool the
movie director went on a rant
during an interview to promote his new
me let me watch I don't need to explain
it when he didn't I I hate these clips
well the real videos on the side but
it's also a and a half minutes
oh that's fresh from channel 4 I think
there might be a good clip I'd it's also
like a knife can I give a good life
advice to anyone who's ever out
promoting something if Channel 4 News
asked you for an interview say hell no
yes hell no news is Krishnan guru-murthy
finally Guinness but why are you so sure
that there's no link between enjoying
movie violence and enjoying real
violence I don't I'm gonna tell you why
I'm so wired do not ask me a question
like that I'm not gonna
not lighting I refuse your question why
because I refuse your question well
what's your premise that there's proof
that there is a correlation like it's
not as burden of proof to disprove also
Tarantino's been dealing with questions
like that for a long time the other one
right guys you're talking about where
he's like cuz it's fun Jan like he's
he's a schmuck oh that one I need that
one and she's like I need that one she's
like why do you put so much violence in
your movies it cuz it's fun and I like
it yeah great answer can you get yeah
the one where he's yelling her name is
Jan - a good memory
yeah it would a question could all that
come from a job I took a way to get you
jacked in the morning Jan I'm not your
slave and you're not my master I'm gonna
make me dance to your tune I call that a
monkey as I'm here to sell my movie
this is a commercial for the movie make
no mistake and you know where I stand on
it which is that there's no relationship
yes but you haven't said why you think
there's no relationship it's just say
your damn business what I think about
that and I have explained it and I have
explained even what you're talking about
I'm just not giving it to you no nice
because I don't want to be like oh you
suck yeah I guess you're not deserving
of it you're not some [ __ ] guy you're
just doing it for clickbait right and
for attention
right and for sensationalism that's all
that's all channel for it does is
apparently damn I didn't really channel
4 was on oh shut er is eating the tripod
yeah eat that [ __ ] eat that tripod
shudder explain this 20 years too much
to kill myself over and over again
because you want me to for you and your
show you're in your ratings guys you
want me to say it for you for your show
this show right here right now are you
getting better as you go once back on to
a question
Tino wanted to answer Krishnan even got
a smile well I think I'm still in the
sweet spot
Wow I'm surprised he oh here we got the
other one yeah I'm surprised you
entertained him after that I know you
know I mean y'all just alright this is a
Greek letter a fine vine interview it's
perfect shredder behaves ready is such a
cutie pie shredder that goes right for
the nose yeah
oh no I don't know why oh I know why I
would take this thing we made a video
edit of this a long time ago but it's
such a wonderful clip that it's only
it's worth the watch Martine I know I
know not even over alright right ears
and Oh tell us what we're about to hear
it's a great fun there's a free strap Oh
figure though it's like one step below
comics and let me sit back go ahead
Marshall okay
years ago they tried to years ago they
tried to put me in it come again because
he's look he wants a life raft so bad oh
he goes uh this is live oh yeah it was
really nice driving like to you know do
another take right you should have taken
a [ __ ] beta blocker good mood and
nailed it how do you get beta blockers
Oh doctors you get it from a doctor no I
mean like you get it from like someone
who has 'm who sells them ah you know ah
same way you get the program okay
same guy but can you is a beta blocker a
prescription drug I believe it is
I don't know exact there's no
over-the-counter version of it I know so
little I have never heard of this
somehow is it a recreational drug well
it's cuz you're not like a like a
concert violinist like me eh
sure like we are yeah like us yeah of
course right the string boys is there a
name for for the google yeah tell me
more baby just get it off Amazon yeah it
does
I don't think beta blockers are are like
the the name of the particular pill
that's what I'm curious what's the name
Dan this is brutal it's trying to answer
the question no just he's locked up Who
am I okay okay okay
years ago they tried to put me in it
this is my buddy I love this talk show
you want to try to read something from
your book yeah yeah god bless ya that's
there's your life raft dude yeah oh you
got it it's taken four blood pressure
and it could also be used for anxiety
okay what's the name of the drug uh
probe run old lol I'm just I'm fell
because I didn't know this was a thing
and you know lol okay they both have
lol's and I'm interesting that that
makes it sound way more I want that more
now they're used they're prescribed
off-label for anxiety what does that
mean well like you know off you go if
you're if you're auditioning for a like
a movie or a play or something it just
keeps you from freaking out in front of
every I didn't know that that was it
that that existed yeah I guess I eat
right Lou up the dirty little secret of
the the concerto business yeah but you
sorry when you took it you didn't feel
necessarily anything just that no you
don't feel anything you just feel like
you know there's there's no cuz I do get
nervous like I remember we were gonna do
the live show I was like I'll [ __ ] I'm
gonna I should take a beta blocker for
the walk right that I would that would
be a good use of it but then again I
would probably get to loose-lipped and
say some crazy too much get extra myself
you need some of those betas don't block
off yeah don't walk off I need something
my baby number yeah I need I need a good
healthy amount of betas right there's a
couple of things call me beta Erik did
we actually [ __ ] made it through this
list that's crazy what we never do that
go us I think I'm gonna grab a beer
anybody want one shredded you have
anything you want to say I'm okay thank
you man
look at this I'm saving it for tomorrow
see you want anything critter morally
some sugar he's thinking oh what a good
well-trained boy he's the face so how
long how long have you had shredder now
I'm trying to do the math here before
for five months hi I'm five months with
this little angel boy and how old you do
we know his age yeah I know his first
ember fourth I know a boy so he still is
a puppy under one year or is it to you
okay I think it's one year when you're
okay oh this little puffer playful
there's really not that much more but
here's a segment I want it to do cuz I I
find that I make fun of social justice
warriors a lot Channel yes yes you do a
lot and I'm I'm a liberal guy mm-hm and
a lot of our fans complain like oh why
don't you make fun of conservatives more
hmm it's eat but I mean my answer that
is well first of all everybody hates
social justice or it's like the easiest
thing ever to make mono it's the safest
thing to make fun of but I finally have
a reason to make fun of conservatives
bring it so here I am very happy to say
you guys saw Michelle Wolf's White House
Correspondents thing yeah yeah brilliant
I saw all these people all these
conservatives who these I'm so afraid of
shredder dying
did you find my chocolate your own
chocolate niblets at that thing that's
cool right
I just got pockets full of it they're
filled with weed and beta blockers
the beta blocker chocolates Oh a little
chance of death just wires just you just
plugged in wires why the wires that's
right so uh this isn't this isn't really
the time to try to make us to get like
be coherent yeah sure it is this is the
party any mistakes I think I know where
he going I think I know where you're
going well it's not that it's not that
it's not good I'm sorry okay no you know
exactly where I'm going right that the
people who are like I'm so outraged how
could I went over the line got in on the
TV talking about snowflakes and a an oh
I'm free speech and you shouldn't and
it's like [ __ ] you you whiny Fox look at
this you don't even need to see what she
said and by the way it wasn't that bad I
thought it was fun Arius I thought it
was
there's some well constructed just as
like if you look at the construction of
the jokes right the I roasts are my
favorite form of comedy sure obviously I
watched this and I was like yeah that's
[ __ ] great great good work and then I
was like oh this is gonna piss a lot of
people off but they do that every year
that's the whole point that's the whole
point right a function of it is kind of
an important one where you give a
comedian that it's almost like the Joker
of old where they get to ask take down
the powers that be for all of us they
get to [ __ ] on the King for lack of
better word and it's an important
function of society it's a really cool
thing yeah Trump's a giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
for not going there to Euro but that's
fine it's a hostile environment it's not
like that playful whatever but um like
George Bush sat there when Colbert
roasted literally next to him yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] in his open mouth and
George Bush was there he took it he took
it like it and you know what like a
roast right that's what you [ __ ] do
for a roast by the way was off track was
last Comedy Central Roast I'm like does
anyone know they're about to roast
somebody yeah they are though it is yeah
Brown that a good sign I don't remember
what it was yeah sorry okay so so yeah
so she also she did a good job of making
fun of everyone by the way she [ __ ] on
liberals conservatives like obviously
you're gonna [ __ ] on the powers-that-be
they're the biggest targets that's the
whole [ __ ] point so she she's really
funny way she spread the women let me
show you some clips of some whining
little [ __ ] losers
oh this isn't it at all the hell is this
there's more cringe compilation what we
do baby fox fox and friends like
coddling her like a little [ __ ]
snowflake like these people are such
sorry I'm so sorry no excuse for that I
mean women shouldn't see what other
women and I just wanted to get your
reaction cuz I thought you handled it
with grace and with class thank you look
I think that the that evening says a
whole lot more about her than it does
about me
the people that were my friends before
that evening or my friends today what
that like as my friends it like any
sense as if she was actually trying to
ruin her life or something maybe they're
still my friends so I clearly came home
ate her tea who made her teeth because I
want to have a word with them first of
all you were a minute apology I know she
I gotta say I'm sorry about that
can I say can I say something you may
how the [ __ ] can you know I'll just say
this how are you expected as a comedian
not to comment on that well the thing
that they a lot of people said was she
was making fun of her looks and if you
watch the whole thing not only doesn't
she's making fun of her makeup barely
but saying like she had a good smoky eye
right or that's kind of what it came but
is but it wasn't like they really that
was never said okay they're acting like
she was up there like this fat [ __ ] is
[ __ ] evil and she gets hit by a car
right what good jokes funny joke but
that's what they were responding yeah
that's what they heard somehow because
they're acting like snow like I'm saying
her tiny right are a [ __ ] disgrace I
think that's a camera trick they need
well she's never actually open her eyes
I go that way like one light John
blasting into her mouth bad lighting
yeah not she's answering you right now
that evening says a whole lot more about
her a whole lot more about you that
doesn't watch her at all you have to
focus on her teeth I'm I know you're
right you're right but you can't point
that out because you know what people
are so you know why we're pointing out
you know why because liberals are so
sensitive
oh it's Fox in the right place I mean I
don't have the best eel it's like get it
kill it
wait a joke liberals you know what I'm
just I'm reveling in this because I
never get the chance and look at these
whiny [ __ ] now yeah it's very know it
is hypocritical isn't it
it is extremely ya know I write to revel
in it that was it that was not a happy
moment apart no Keith look like an
upside down graveyard Wow
Oh Oh crib def all right I could play
some nice ping-pong against you win
today my friends before that evening or
my friends today and I'm going to
continue doing as if one of my friends
was like goof you got that's not a
coherent like wait no it doesn't yeah
like that makes no sense the people I'm
proud to say that the people who were my
friends yesterday are still my friends
just goof I'm not talking about your
friends dude I don't mean the job that I
came here to do every single day I'm
very proud of the fact that I work in
this administration for this president
and we're gonna keep pushing forward and
doing everything we can to make America
better and I think we've had a great
first year and a half at doing that a
huge success story that we're proud of
and I hope that she can find some of the
same happiness that we all have because
I think she may need a little bit more
of that in her life because the rest of
us here are doing great you're wrong she
made some joke I'm good I don't I don't
think I'm happy no I hope she finds a
happier life Inc they're really unhappy
Dennis Miller's tweets this supposed o
median well I used to be a fan of Dennis
Miller sure sure sure I love this
football commentary really yeah you
could really tell he's a fan of sports I
keep forgetting that he that's the thing
yeah he's like the is like the the sack
of the Goths against the Black Sea yeah
and now it's a touchdown
right he said what a horrid human being
Michelle wolf is I'm gonna read up on
her over the next couple of days and
I'll have a few brutally mean jokes
about her by Wednesday what I love did
we miss out on his jokes well here's the
thing I think I never hated the pro the
burst bubbles and you guys's balloons
but what happened was I think
immediately after this he went on
Facebook and said you know what I'm
actually not gonna do it like yeah he
backpedaled [ __ ] hardcore and I don't
know it's been like so like two so two
days ago and Wednesday like all the come
all the other comedians were tweeting
out like
it's Dennis Miller don't they it was
like you're actually really funny like
pigs out of it like here we go guys
but it never happened and unfortunately
on the 29th I think later that very day
or maybe there was a 30th he actually
backpedaled [ __ ] hardcore and said
you know what he left it up and what's
all he left me he left this tweet up he
left that suite up that's kind of weird
that he did that I feel like he did
actually somewhere on one of his social
media platforms he backpedaled and said
I'm not going to do the Wednesday thing
but not enough people saw that so that's
why we did it
he never tweeted it it's like yo I got
more likes on this tweet than I haven't
alone yeah yeah he was like all right
yeah first she was never done I just as
a comedian is that not the lamest [ __ ]
ever I'm gonna take a couple days and
study up on this that's very very enough
to come up with something on right now
give me a couple days I'll be I'll get
you back on Wednesday such a [ __ ] cop
out is such a cop-out I loved for a guy
that's like you know is witty or like as
well-versed as this guy is you think
he'd come up with something but nope
well I'll tell you what Dennis on by
Monday I'm gonna do some research
yeah there you go by next Friday take
the weekend take a weekend I next Friday
I'm gonna come back with some also great
wait can you pull his Twitter back up I
would love to see I got that that
profile picture again how long ago was
this [ __ ] picture of him days Janis
what the hell this is this is really
innate it in like 10 by 10 pixels this
is this is his headshot that got him
hired on demon night back in 1995 nice
forever sorry demon note Karen it demon
night demon night wait am I right about
that was a demon lighter was a bordello
of blood what the [ __ ] is is a neo he
was in a Tales from the Crypt movie oh
really
bordello how do you even know fine this
low-res of a photo yeah that's such an
obscure reference that's I know in our
school no you know I killed it well not
all I mean yeah not all Twitter avatars
have the highest res I'm sure she's got
sounded he's following six people oh
[ __ ] let's are you [ __ ] guys damn it
that's for fine I'll check well that's
it guys that's all we got ah man did we
learn man this was like a journey today
this starts with the grandma [ __ ] oh
yeah all the way to here
God was crazy I feel like to me imagine
that with a Kodak better yet imagine me
in Times Square with a Kodak right now
negative and positive keep going man
that's all I just say tonight just say
tonight and sing-songy tones for about
three minutes and got yourself a [ __ ]
hit we closed it before you like slime
but it also ended with tonight oh I like
that man I want too I'll come prepared
with a good pit bull verse because whoo
the people don't need to see the sausage
being made I'll just find the best one
you are a good game beat is you like is
it a pitbull lyric or is it a blah blah
blah like maybe you make up your own
thing Oh like you have to genius like
real pitbull ooh oh my god Eric maybe
there's like a like is it a pitbull
lyric or is it like Shakespeare all
right that might be too easy that's a
tough there's not your attraction yeah
like Michael Buble mm no I really like
people or did we just make this up on
the spot I think that's really [ __ ]
funny oh there's so much write that down
that'll have these guys put that
together we can all play it again funny
dude that's a great idea I love it I
love yeah nice try Jimmy Fallon we took
we got them all right well it's Friday
right yeah I think it's Friday last week
we did it like on a Monday and it [ __ ]
my whole like month up oh I can't
imagine oh this is like this is how you
mark my week these podcasts yeah your
anchors I'm stuck in a timeless void
without this on Friday this is this is
hunting out all of the steam from the
week before right right
[Music]
how'd you find the chocolate shred he's
not your boy here grid that lightning
and [ __ ] blood
someone has thanks for watching hope you
have a
great absolutely magic fantastic weekend
you guys got anything going on you want
the people to be after you yeah I'm just
gonna say uh come Monday I'm going to
announce a new not not just new March a
new line of my I've been teasing for the
last like month and a half or so it's
been I've been working on this since
January so I'm really really really
really excited it looks awesome
I'm wearing now thank you very very much
yeah this is just a tip of the iceberg
this is just part of it but um Monday it
gets its own video it's not what is it
tell me about it cuz you you had this
whole story yeah so it's it's called
it's called be a Klondike um and it's
just based off like like don't be a
fuck-boy don't be savage don't be just
an awful human being be someone nice
like my dog Klondike it was just a
sweetheart like she's she's loyal she is
loving and she pees a little every time
she sees me cuz you know overjoyed she's
just a kind old soul so I'm trying to
encourage people to be less of like this
whole [ __ ] boy Savage culture that's you
know popular and like just just be kind
like what happened to being like good
and decent and kind so like be a
Klondike be a Klondike that's what's
coming up on a Monday it looks really
yeah thank you very much that means a
lot you guys really came out great
the race is honestly I have to say this
is the this is the best merch I've ever
come out with cuz like stitching I've
never had [ __ ] stitching before so
this is thank you
yeah that's in the crates back backstage
I got some Obama made my frog gay shirts
for you guys I said you mean embroidery
embroidery yes yes embroider is Adam you
got me there cool what about you um man
it's been a while since I made a video
so look out for that guys just wait and
I hit you with one of those soon just
you wait are you working on one yeah
well I got a little bit uh I'm trying to
make them a little more more
high production value something put in
skits in Oh stuff I want to film some
stuff with you guys right after the to
wit I got some really fun stuff that I'm
working on nice is your next one a let's
go to class or a or the the other it's
lesson that's it's gonna be how to avoid
the the NSA or my how to avoid
surveillance yeah eight I love it
already I'm in I'm in tree yeah there's
a lot there's a lot going on in it
there's gonna be some blood some squibs
going off
yes equip squibs everywhere away up baby
it's a fake like gun hit have you guys
ever seen those like like work they're
crazy
I worked on a show that had squibs and
yeah it's like a strip like they put a
vest on you and there's like a strip
that's got [ __ ] gun powder in it wow
that's connected to a detonator and they
detonate these things on your chest but
they put like a like a metal protect
it's almost like being child it can go
wrong but like it can send like shrapnel
into you if it does if they put too much
gum fat OH
so these like any time you see someone
shot less risky then then a real bullet
yeah and you really don't get many takes
with it either because you got a set the
whole [ __ ] thing up yeah got a
redress so your next video has tons of
squibs going yeah and you can tell it's
take four because it's our way you
squibbed for real I know no I've never
actually squid but I've been with I've
been present for squiding right and it's
fun it's fun to watch but it's like
nail-biting because you're like better
[ __ ] get it the first time around or
else everybody's not eating right or
else we're not eating right yeah these
squibs are important squibs are
important or else I don't get to eat
right Gotti name my memoir so I'm
looking forward to our week off although
it's not really a week off because we
got two videos we have to finish and we
have a video on Monday we have to record
so this weekend already feels like it's
not a real vacation oh no
but we're gonna disconnect alright
you're gonna bit connect is that we're
gonna do like a social media detox yeah
yeah that's so smart it's gonna say I
envy this thing sound like in concept
like when you think of it in a very
abstract way you're like oh why would
that ever be necessary and then you
realize yes it's like I catch myself all
the [ __ ] time yes like it's awful
like I'm not even reading I'm just the
muscle mention of it that's the game to
me
well we mean either were talking earlier
just we just realized now more than ever
like how bad it's gotten for us yeah and
that it's actually like negatively
impacting our life it needs to go back
to the way it was before where it was
just like this fun little gimmick that
yeah right that's not something that it
was that over the longest time was yeah
it was when you first get Twitter like I
didn't have I still have an Instagram
but like getting Twitter it actually or
somebody posing as me on Instagram I'm
watching it it starts to it does start
to become like that's what your eyes
want to spend time on and it should be
just literally anything else yeah and I
agree anything so that's smart you take
you take a week off go ahead as you guys
I'm including emails to that's another
thing I don't know my dad emails me know
their father gotta read them yeah well
business emails yeah we fit it we should
change our passwords and make them hold
them how quickly would you guys turn
that away crackheads yeah nothing you
like just attack him
[Laughter]
just ignore him like I've stepped I got
an inbox with like 8,000 done Reds you
know and it's just it's wonderful the
thing is it's not that bad for me but
HeLa has all these Teddy fresh emails
and everything about what though like
like just like like like questions and
queries about like okay designs
production got it she needs to make a
decision on or nothing moves that's
annoying
if I reorder something then we need to
get the fabrics again and then if the
color doesn't match for example it's a
whole thing
God all kinds of stuff it's like really
like like deep-set like I didn't realize
you were that far into the type I like
like choosing the fabrics and stuff yeah
you guys go to Joshua Tree
take some sure there you go there you go
yeah let it roll I really just I
honestly off the grid I just want some
beta blockers and blockers every day
I'll hook you up with some beta blockers
where you get those B if I don't know a
guy where'd you get them the ones you
took uh no comment well hook me up yeah
I got a guy for you then beta blockers
no I know I know someone who does though
what the [ __ ] how did I miss this I saw
that was more savvy Ian just said he
does Ian you take beta blockers can you
get him on the mic Dan yeah I wasn't
gonna out him but I was talking about
you yeah but puttin on the mic bill
cosby's my doctor there is dr. Huxtable
is that Ian you take beta blockers yeah
is it a prescription drug well yeah they
gave it to me because I have that hand
tremor it's supposed to help with that
can you talk wait damn get them closer
to the mic a little bit yeah but do you
notice other so it helps with the hand
trimmer but does it it doesn't help with
that whatsoever doesn't help with the
hand trimmer but does it help with other
stuff take more so so in short it did
nothing for you okay you know how we're
gonna figure this out and we're gonna
take you to a kendrick lamar concert
we're gonna get you up on stage and fill
you with beta-blockers right and we're
gonna see how well you perform are you
freaking out right now yes we're gonna
have to double your dosage come on I
want to know what's up with
beta-blockers is this a new thing I
don't know how I know this is I mean I
remember hearing about it for as long as
like like like I think kids in my high
school would take him before huh
like like auditions and stuff but it was
always that sort of what about xanax
whatever happened to xanax why'd the
world become xanax might be too chemical
you know I think it might have too much
of an effect I think beta blockers are
sort of more subtle stuff yeah you don't
feel like you're taking something
illicit when you take it is a very
slight effect it's really just for blood
pressure you're not gonna notice
anything everyone at homes getting we
got two guys in there to take them
though so I might be talking about my
[ __ ] ass wait two guys Danny Dan
doesn't take oh I thought that's what
that was talking about Ian wait was the
guy you know and an alright alright
that's it that's all we got guys I guess
we'll see you in two weeks
right yeah see me a long time I'm gonna
miss y'all you guys should all
disconnect yeah look of it let's all
disconnect everyone watching who's up
for it and let's kind of revisit that
would be what we'll talk about our first
app back and see kind of how that worked
out for us I think you guys are gonna
look great I might and my colors gonna
come back colors 20 years younger
yeah feel like my age has accelerated a
lot recently you guys are gonna you're
gonna be like doing like you're not me a
helper so I was just gonna start doing
push-ups in the middle of those bugs
just instinctively yeah just because you
feel like it am I gonna stop ordering
pizzas in the podcast because I'm not
you might know you'll just order more
pizzas which is fine yes I did a couple
push-ups I can eat ten more slaps a
[ __ ] lutely I thought it works baby
you just get the cheese and the meat
right no bread no bread no bright get a
pizza no crunch they would eat the ball
just a pizza ball that'd be kind of dank
when it comes in a cup Eric Andre did a
bit about pizza balls as one of his uh
how did I miss it
Oh is there a new season out no no not
yet it's been it's been a while since I
heard him promoting it on Howard Stern
Rico [ __ ] really if you like some
specials where he went to Paris for like
a bit but I was like and I say I didn't
really like that yeah it wasn't I'm
gonna have to agree with you there like
as much as I wish I wanted to drive I
wanted to like it yeah it was his best
not yo [ __ ] yeah season 5
premiere what February 18th
we missed it
what no that can't be right I can't
[ __ ] be three months ago Eric Andre
season 5 premiere oh this is okay no I'm
wrong it's the air compares why would
they say that that's all that is so wait
are there any news about a new season
premiere that guy's my [ __ ] like
probably top one comedy Idol right now
my store once [ __ ] you man I'm so
jealous I keep it but it took a stopped
them oh really you did what was it was
not a glorious sorry to interrupt your
story it wasn't much of a story I saw me
way do I recognize them and I was like
freak them out I'm looking at in Studio
City the other day I saw the Nathan
Nathan Nathan fielder yeah with both a
friend and then it took me everything
like again I I cut down I got a I got a
what do you what do you [ __ ] say to
him like I got a selfie with both of
them in the same night I paint you where
were you we were you know math mark oh
he's okay he's a musician and he invited
us to his concert and and Eric and
Nathan are both fans of his but the
thing is that Mac is gets a little bit
of a party animal so we were sipping
tequila the whole time like what I was
trashed
yeah and then Eric and and Nathan roll
up I'm like first ice first Nathan come
and he's hanging out and I'm like I'm
trashed
I'm blackout drunk and this is when I
was like in the midst of my biggest like
I was just a super fan I was i I said
yeah I love the guy but I was in the
middle of watching a show and I was like
this guy's a [ __ ] genius I love
everything he does and so he rose up
with his girlfriend and I'm like I have
to say something because he's hanging
out with he's not he's hanging out with
the same people I'm hanging out with
Jesus and so as I came in I'm a big fan
of your show I was like borderline
blackout drunk and he's like I don't
know he'll it was more sober than me so
yeah but he's like man you me do YouTube
that's cool how do you make money
YouTube stuff and like eat well he
thinks it was horrible I don't think it
was
horrible that horrible like you're
describing you're drunk
well what about I was drunk you sober
and I was just talking about YouTube for
like 30 minutes and he's like alright
cool man
bye I couldn't he's a lot like gays in
his show so I couldn't tell if it was
like a bit or not started breaking
plates over as you were talking to him
wrong guy right because that would be
very reason to say yeah yeah because I
was drunk I was fanboy which is
something I hate and would never do and
I've always in my mind imagine what I
would be like if I met them because
those two guys are like the two comedy
people that I actually probably the only
two yes and like maybe Tim Heidecker yes
I would like fanboy over same and so I
was like I had in my mind like being all
cool and being like hey nice to meet but
I was that when you've had to kill all
night if it was so embarrassing
ah and then after that we went and Eric
Andre was also hanging out got something
we were walking off and he was walking
up and I ran up to him like a little
[ __ ] s fangirl I was like hey Eric can
I get a picture and he he's like yeah
just don't post on Instagram because I
don't want people to know that I'm in
disguise
I still have I've never posted those
pictures that I'm in into guys no
disguise in disguise he told me not yeah
I don't think he would yeah you wouldn't
care if you were into guys are here guys
got it ecstatic
like you didn't tag Nita I mean in
disguise but I wasn't no embarrassing i
I don't know I cringe so hard when I
think about that it's so tragic no I
meant are you kidding and when it's not
magic I'm sober never even posted those
pictures so they're just sitting there
just to put it on my effective his
bright people who feel the same way
about meetings they've had with you you
walked away and you were like I was fine
that was cool and they walked away they
were like [ __ ] up no yeah what am what
fool I am
yeah but it doesn't make it any less
real sure I get that I get that it's a
feeling you'll have to carry with you
yeah I'll carry that
that cross for every model but anytime I
get drunk the next day when I think
about it it always seems like yes so
cringy / yeah oh yeah I think that's
just a universal instinctual feeling
well I mean until you get them on the
show and then you know then who's
laughing gonna see who the [ __ ] doubt
I can absolutely imagine that not you're
like I'm dead forever now they're back
you bitch-ass fanboy I'm not not your no
offense they're not gonna remember this
you too [ __ ] yeah man boy damn boy I'm
gonna loser you will have them on
there's mark my words you will have one
of them if not both of them on the show
at some point Wow I can I can absolutely
are you can see it when they're when
they're suing you like Eric was on hot
one obviously and right now that would
be a weird serve me the papers
that's a weird prank but now if they
ever come on the show now I feel like do
you remember you have to bring it was
drunk and they won't they will not
remember no I don't feel really and it
will be awkward I was like oh yeah
do you want to read a section from your
book what if that's the whole book this
is lunch over and over again you like to
report I am Mar you know here's ago
years ago there's like two blank pages
you know if that guy had some beta
blockers on me and you probably would I
think so yeah I think beta blockers
whole podcast is just a three hour
commercial for beta blockers up doctor
Eric here check out the neon grisly
dot-com Store for all the hottest
internet comedy beta blockers have their
illegal our beta blockers illegal yeah I
mean if I do them they are they
because he doesn't high interest and
beta blockers in in if you and if you
get like extra like pills
like every time we do a podcast I tell
you about something that like like
there's bug chasers yeah yeah the bug
chasing that's that's a funny bit and
like the thing is like you have to
figure out what Avenue because it's
really not a funny thing it's like a sad
weird like crazy thing that people do
there is like a trajectory to take to
find the center of that joke there's
nailing all over that oh I mean I'm not
gonna disagree I mean there's nothing
hilarious about aids and if you get like
extra beta blockers can we saw it as h3
official no a lot of people here want to
try it
put a little Teddy fresh logo on them
right [ __ ] look just acebos well shut
up salt like a drug deal like 100 for a
pill will call it ends beta block I'll
cut you in a mo but not a lot I mean
that's that's a stupidly good deal
better take it in I mean she Crowley's
in jail so which means there's a big
hole in market big opening he's not
watching right Frank he's in prison
watching on what a brick like I'm
watching TV this is my TV gerald man
that guy's in prison for real wasn't
that so great how like oh what if Bill
Cosby Quayle is Martin so yeah then
charges him for it right my bill yeah
that's gonna cost you two cigarettes
both very wealthy I can't do it good you
know Justin roiland Cosby he's good with
the voice the house of Cosby's right the
one time I ever met him I was like two
House of Cosby's is the funniest [ __ ]
thing I think I've ever seen hmm
I just had to tell him mm-hmm that was
my hypochondria story yeah I walked away
I was like yeah yeah I think I impressed
them too much you probably enjoyed that
no it's not like isn't that fine that is
our instinctual reaction to someone we
respect we tell them why we like what
they mean right when I saw patton oswalt
like for a brief second one night I told
him like I just want to tell you I
[ __ ] think your stand-up is brilliant
I love the I just loved the vocabulary
you use blah blah and it's something
like like why do we it's like word vomit
we have to tell them everything we love
about that person and their craft how
much of that is like so that we can go
to our friends and and and make it sound
like it was much I don't know because I
haven't like I I think it's just I think
it's less of a of a humble brag and much
more of a admission of like I have to
tell you like what you mean to me I
don't know like no you're right there's
is that back Larry David you would you
would but you would say by the way the
people who come up to me on the street
the ones that I appreciate the most
wants who they don't ask for a selfie or
anything they just say hey whatever like
you said you know this is what it means
Thanks
totally she the guy screamed salvia Eric
at me out of a car as it was passing by
how did that feel it took me a second to
like because they were coming up to a
red light and the guy went solve you
Eric you know she crosses you and they
drove off that was a fan doing response
and they just peeled away how'd that
feel it felt great it really emboldened
me for the rest of the day
I got everything on my list on vodka I
need to know you know what good friends
I think we should set up something where
yeah set up like a 2:00 p.m. dress fine
we just lift each other up and that's
all we do we just scream some meme you
know at each other that we're known Oh
done me me big boy right right yeah
the joke is to try to get it the most
ridiculous person possible selected like
in a [ __ ] Mack truck right passing by
like me me big boy he doesn't watch
right right right right big fan right
like sir you're 70 alright alright so
this time it's over for real right it
feels like it I love this was a Lord of
the Rings what do you like about lower
than favorite no you did there's no see
if I can did I am as long as I have this
thing in front of my face I'm gonna keep
talking just like Kanye yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah Wow we circled the [ __ ] up any
more of these until he starts out like
that
well we're turning although we're
turning the cameras off doesn't mean
that we're not turning up ourselves
good wine see you everyone at home I
wish you all would turn up this weekend
but safely and use those beta blockers
responsibly because they are legal if
you don't have a prescription for them
apparently that's right although
apparently it doesn't do anything I've
asked everyone that I know is taking it
and they all say it doesn't do anything
so I don't know basically just a B
vitamin I mean I'm I'll be your beta
blocker in life I'll just sighs your
shoulders before a thing and be like
okay absolutely see you doing that a
beta blocker it almost sounds like like
it's making you more alpha like that's
why it blocks all those Kuck in your
blood yang and thank you that [ __ ]
alpha makes you a Chad if just Chad's
you up dude yeah if you eat soy you
bleed out of your eyes
alright don't eat soy on beta-blockers
right ironically that's what soy boys
take [ __ ] the beta box yeah alpha
makers is what they should call him
seriously
[Laughter]
all right guys have a great weekend
we'll see you in two weeks
detox everybody remember look up from
your cell phones look up she is
good bye love y'all thanks for watching
goodbye now